welcome everybody to the h3 podcast
today I am sitting here with the
illustrious and beautiful fashion icon
Neel Klein ela kleiner what up you thank
you for their amazing introduction
you're welcome dude I would you deserve
that and more frankly I just ran out of
words but come on there's got to be way
more words to describe that oh my mom is
watching Wow
ela Kleiner's the original ela kleiner
the Elana
client Wow welcome EULA's mom to the
stream so today guys we're gonna mix it
up we're doing it a little bit
differently so today we don't have a
guest we may have a special guest
stopping by later but today's just me
and ela because it's important to us to
have some kind of format we can do once
so month at least where it's just us and
we have some kind of show format
something to talk about where we're not
reliant on a guest to come every time so
we can make sure that we always have a
show for you guys every week and
basically what we've put together for
you guys is top of the month which is
something we want to do once a month
maybe even more if you guys like it
where we go over basically our favorite
news items our favorite videos all the
great little things to talk about every
month and we have like a great list of
stuff videos to watch stuff to talk
about it should be a lot of fun
I'm excited sometimes we'll have guests
to come sit with us sometimes not but
today it's me and ela
what up ela Kleiner's hopefully that
sounds fun to you guys and to out people
out there on YouTube remember that you
can tune in to this every week live 3
p.m. PST at twitch.tv 4 / h3h3
productions oh [ __ ] post is coming
alright nice we got post Mon joining us
so it's gonna be a chain-smoking
surprise guest yeah no surprise anymore
last time Austin was here post Malone
like everyone's like oh [ __ ] Ethan
smokes I don't smoke I only smoke when
I'm with pulse because how can you not
he's like mr. camel crush and but lion I
don't drink either by the way when I
don't hang out them so there's gonna be
a chain-smoking Bud Light drinking yeah
I'm always like I'm almost getting into
the smoking tube but I gotta be a good
one
don't smoke kids one day angel well the
thing is when I smoke I'm getting old
right I'm 31 you guys I'm ashamed to
admit that and it's almost my birthday
my birthday don't tell anyone cuz it's
embarrassing god I'm like the oldest
[ __ ] loser on YouTube people must
look at me and be like this guy people
look at me I see this come all the time
that guy's 50 I swear to god they're
like wow he's only 31 humiliating it's
the white hairs I mean what can you do
it but you eating it put on the baby
weight are you horrified are you saying
put on the beanie do you see this oh my
wife talks she goes put on poop back on
the beanies yeah I'm sure it looks
insane but I'm a comedian right I'm
trying to make a joke I know it looks
crazy but actually Ethan had white hair
when I met him when he was 21
yeah already runs in the family but it's
definitely a lot worse now than it was
but they already had a lot I did have a
lot anyway I think you've been at 18 I
was starting to go grey but the good
news is for me full head of hair baby
well maybe even too much hair I'm saying
God please just make me bought a little
bit could help me out you got good hair
I got good hair bye anyway what was I
saying was saying like what the [ __ ] was
I saying I have no idea guys what was
they say yeah anyway uh well be what oh
yeah so anyway I was saying I'm 31 now
and when I like when I was a kid I in
college I used to smoke it's disgusting
first of all let me just say this it's
disgust smoking is a disgusting don't do
it when I was at college I used to smoke
and now that I'm an adult I get like I
have a cigarette and I feel like I'm
have a heart attack
like I sit here in cell chain-smoker
then next day I have like a full-on
throat infection it's gets hard
seriously
smoking just like your body is just
telling you
don't I know it does basically that's
what it is like I don't know how you
ever get addicted to smoking cuz what
people don't realize is you have to put
in a lot of work to get addicted to
smoking right it's like it doesn't feel
good it hurts it's expensive it makes
you stink like there's literally nothing
redeeming about the act of it and I
still don't really understand the
redeeming act of it some people like it
it takes a lot of work to get addicted
to smoking cigarettes it's a really
interesting thing we used to smoke I met
you when you're in the Israeli army yeah
used to smoke the gnarly [ __ ] till dude
you got to be real with me
like you can't be sometimes we'll make
videos in heels like well what if my
parents watch this okay I'm like dude
we're trying to this is our livelihood
we just tell my brother to close this
stream right now cuz watching it with
him what they don't know that you smoked
ever smoked two cigarettes Cola it's
like I have this thing where like I'm
one of these people that I'll never be
able to I'll never smoke next to my
parents I just can't do it
alright or tell them that I smoked even
though they probably know cuz they've
seen me in a picture before I mean it's
respectful
that's a nice thought just the way I I
can't do it it's respectful nice but on
the other hand maybe take a little too
far when you're like I in my head can't
tell talk about this right can I get a
couple of what ups but you you you did
used to smoke yeah when I was in the
Army everyone smokes in their army it's
like it's like you get your uniform and
you get a pack of cigarettes with it
yeah that is true I used to smoke but I
was never like a serious smoker
it was never addicted or like felt like
I have to go smoke it was really good I
did it for the fun I think I just have
an addictive personality like there's a
pack of cigarettes on the counter I
don't smoke I don't care about
cigarettes but it's like I have to smoke
them all and I'll make myself sick it's
a weird it's a weird thing yeah
it's bizarre yeah what else don't you
want your parents to know about you're
scared now I could [ __ ] her whole [ __ ]
up right now
yeah like for example when we were
making the video about we used to be
drug dealers
I've been Santa Cruz Deva was like I
can't make this video because what if my
parents watch and I'm like dude this our
career like I don't think they care at
this point
they also this happened like 10 years
ago this is how India's header parent
okay also another thing I'll never curse
in front of my parents such a sweet kid
I just can't do it you gotta practice it
say crap now say something now it's good
it's therapy say [ __ ] I can say that but
in here boy it's what's that good to
keep recurse work to Semak is that a
curse good it's pretty good not like
very it's not very vulgar oh it's not
what's like the most vulgar Hebrew word
Ben zona so Ben zone on Hebrew means son
a [ __ ] yeah or son of a prostitute or
something literally for some reason
that's like people in the Middle East
are all like Mama's boys and [ __ ] so
that's like the real fighting words
benzo not oh yeah have you call someone
a benzo na and Tel Aviv you better
[ __ ] decade boy cuz those Israelis
they got a temper man they're crazy did
you have any good people are saying you
threaded the wrong link no [ __ ] no don't
do this to me
you gotta be kidding me this can't be I
hope they're trolling I'm such a [ __ ]
that picture of me is so suiting right
now this is the eighth in that tweeted
tell a close-up of that picture this is
the Dom the shoenice Ethan that tweeted
the wrong link on Twitter not once but
twice but I seriously blame my phone the
autocorrect on this thing is atrocious
it's so insane okay
try this [ __ ] again dude I don't want to
talk to you about Samsung because I do
like I do like Samsung as a brand dude
but the autocorrect not the best because
I had a knife one before just switched
it in u.s.a
I love the Samsung phone I think it's
the best phone by far the new one is is
is wonderful I don't know what's with
the autocorrect I don't know if it's
like a machine-learning thing right but
not it's not correct
like you'll type ID ID and then it'll
switch it to like it I'm like that's a
word you don't need to switch it to
another word that's already a word you
guys like these autocorrect rants I got
to type this again you guys I'm sorry
I'm such an absolute loser twitch.tv
Ford / Eli have a question for you I was
just at the urinal before we went live
to take a piss as you do in the bathroom
as is often what you do in the bathroom
mm-hmm and I was thinking like I have
something called stage fright yeah I get
it sometimes like if I'm in the bathroom
I'm taking a piss and somebody comes in
sings next to me something I can't pee I
don't know why I get like stage fright
yeah I know that feeling worried when
you can't because like waiting I was
gonna ask you is the do girls have the
same thing it would take me like another
two minutes probably is there like
anything else that I'm not thinking
about where women have that kind of
stage fright thing like what goes on
there what's the secret world of women
in the bathroom well that's a really
general question what do you got dude
there's gotta be something fascinating
I'm not sure I don't know I didn't
prepare for this
do you ever poop next to a woman and
it's like awkward like like as girls I
feel like it's I find it just funny
about
girls pooping so like you're in a stall
because every girl sits down right okay
that's all you got a person right no in
the men's bathroom you have urinals okay
and the women's bathroom just stalls so
there must be a lot of like pooping and
peeing going on there and you just maybe
you get sit next to a pooper when you've
got that you're gonna be next to a beer
and then all of a sudden you're in for a
little while to ride then you you know
signed up for does that ever happen yeah
what you can I get more thoughts on that
I mean it's it's what you think it would
be it's a bathroom
you don't like to stay there too long
you do you do your stuff and you get out
what about this you're going into poop
and you thought you were next to appear
but all the sudden now you have to
Cooper's next to each other and then
you're kind of both like this topic for
Friday afternoon I'm honestly just
trying to make this correct this tweet
right if you p.m. PST h3 podcast time
every week bro
I actually don't know if that ever
happened to me where I like me and
another person next to me we're pooping
at the same time seriously in the public
restroom like how often is that well
that's kind of I'm getting now you get
into the heart of what's interesting
here EULA because girls only sit at
stalls but you're talking about public
restrooms right yeah I guess I'm yeah
yes so I don't poop in a public restroom
that often I try to avoid it at all cost
what I'm wondering is sometimes you sit
down to pee and oops you sit down to pee
well I don't okay but I'm saying like
maybe as did you turn up saying no you
sit down to pee and that's also in your
poopy no that guy's more that would only
happen to me at home not in a public
place I know exactly what I'm going to
do it
I loved it this like this one on one
with the alleges turn into like I'm
asking about her whole gender yeah duh
before
we get into the top of the month I want
to say we don't have a sponsor this
episode of the podcast if you want to
support the show if you like what you do
and you if you like what we do and you
want to see more here's how you can
support us number one we just drop some
new merch like a mother effing God
Church or should I say flipping this is
actually this is actually the coolest
merch I think we've ever had
represent calm Ford / h3 h3 yeah mm-hmm
pick it up here helos also wearing one
you should show the back of it it's
really yet are you showing me right now
it's actually a wonderful design I
really like it they did a great job
so represent com4 slash h3 h3 make sure
to tuck it also if you don't want to
spend any money and you want to support
us it's easy free money thanks to Amazon
if you connect your Amazon Prime account
which I know you have because every
person in the world has it by now you
can subscribe to us every month for free
it's amazing it's the best so even if
you don't have money please you can
support the show if you like it and you
want to see more connect your Amazon
account with your Twitter account
subscribe with Amazon Prime and you get
you can do it every month once a month
so come back Riis absque Ribe thank you
so much to Amazon for that really cool
thing and thank all you guys for your
continued support we love you we
appreciate you so much with that being
said let's get right into the flippin
news bro what do we got on the list
dealer sure most of you guys by now have
seen Jake Paul's everyday bro we made a
video about it I think everybody in the
whole flippin YouTube has made a video
about it at this point
he had a live show I think last night
and it is just an absolute riot like man
this dare I say it's it's even worse
than the video they're they're
lip-syncing and they can't even get the
sync right which is just absolutely
fascinating so I'm Mike
my objective here is to see who are his
fans right and I want a little learn a
little bit more about all these people
on stage as well I want to see what's
their skill set Sam where are they right
listen sever look go back to the
beginning I see complaining so there's
something really weird where it's not
change at all yeah this video I couldn't
find a clean version but like imagine
this imagine this you have like kids
like ten cameras there mm-hmm this is
like a huge production and it's not even
synced it's like a complete failure and
this is the only one available to it so
you got a total failure find that
fascinating I really like that beginning
there I'm like boy white boy
[Music]
it's insane yeah it's absolutely bananas
it's it's absolutely bananas I love that
people who just have no musical talents
they're just like I'll just make rap
yeah I'd say it's kind of like a new
fashion it's just so easy to make you
don't have to sing like first of all
there are musical geniuses who rap yeah
but the format itself lends itself to
two people with no talent so that seems
to be like the fallback
but I loved its just lip synching and
he's not even really trying to stay on
there I guess I don't know I don't I
feel like I don't want to also criticize
him too much cuz I don't know if he's
like pretending to be like the next
great singer you know what I mean it's
more like a fun show for his fans
ya know I think that's probably true to
it it's just I didn't know I think it's
important to be somewhat mature about
these situations like I don't think that
he thinks he's like yeah Frank Sinatra
he's I don't know if he's trying to
launch a music career that would be kind
of disturbing if he was actually trying
to go like full-on music career and
something tells me just by the nature
that he put on this show kind of that he
is I don't know but anyway it's
important to be mature and not not get
to like yeah I mean he's putting on a
the show is free by the way for his fans
alright let's watch sorry
[Music]
I like oh he's already kind of out of
breath he's kind of a fit young guy what
I'm relating I feel like I would be this
just to like immediately out of breath I
can't relate cuz I would never even put
myself in addition to be out of breath
roll it he literally forgot the dirt
works he doesn't know the words to his
own song there are also like I feel like
I just why I know the lyrics I already
know it go back a little bit I just want
to confirm that you forgot the words
it's back a little bit more
what is that yeah what was that so you
go on man so I once song he only did one
song so posit fuzz but this guy is the
true star wait oh yeah I want to show to
the audience let's let's analyze this
[ __ ] back yeah pretty young kids are
they 12 or even younger twelve and a
half you think they're older than twelve
they're clearly kids though
I mean anyone over the age of fifteen
their I think would probably rather jump
off an overpass there at the age that
counts half still they still count house
oh they're young twelve and a half huh
good point that's a really good point
Jake Paul is like the dude who you think
is badass when you're 12 and that's when
you hit 13 you're like you take down to
Jake Paul posters roll it yeah and no
thanks for clarifying like even he seems
to be missing he's missing his line
50 too much security
now I'm falling off like nag knew
[Music]
yeah I should probably take over so yeah
this guy here let's do a switch this is
let's do it during the break this is so
this guy he goes you were hating on me
back in Westlake which is a which is a
line I really love because Westlake is
like a super affluent village in LA in a
really beautiful part of LA like you're
not you don't live in Westlake most
likely and let you're like a really rich
white person it's like yeah that's like
super annoying it's like The Truman Show
or some [ __ ] I don't know you were
hating on me back in Westlake
but now I made it and I live on Vine
Street in Hollywood made it it's a fun
little detail anyway I don't think we
need to watch the whole show do we yeah
let's watch yeah oh yeah we gotta watch
it what are you kidding I don't miss
this for the world
oh there you going that worked there you
go sorry guys this isn't old zest is the
first time we're doing this so we're
cleaning it up hopefully that's not
Michelle it should be okay and no I'm
not from Compton okay okay here we go
that crowd is really popping
look at this it's like a hey this looks
like a middle school assembly and they
bring all the kids and he's given like a
presentation on safe sex or something I
[Music]
love how they don't have enough mics for
everyone like this is this is so sad how
he passes the mic off look at this [ __ ]
he's like alright I guess I'm not even
gonna finish the line I guess my 15
minutes is are up Jake here's your mic
back look at this [ __ ]
here you go Doug I'm gonna go sneak on
to the back of the line now see ya hey
Jake thanks for the opportunity I'm
gonna have him head on back to Westlake
here watch this it's so sad he's like
damn can we get these little espanol
twinks out here
[Music]
yeah yeah so these kids were kind of
like they have like the the good verse
that everyone's talking about in the
song but they kind of sound like the
worst almost they sound like children
their voice they're all high-pitched and
[ __ ] they are too like just the fact
that he's on stage singing leave link to
merch and bio and I'll see you tomorrow
cuz it's everyday bro like it's just not
badass it is great but it's just there's
no dignity I feel like you can't say
that on stage it should be some kind of
taboo like there should be a huge pain
like the old timey cane that just comes
and scoops you off stage when you say
Lincoln bio see you tomorrow on stage
during a song
[Music]
like what happened you missed the whole
Oh anyway I like I said yeah no can't
hate on the kid yeah too much I mean
yeah he's out there shaking his dick
doing his thing so god bless him but at
the same time it's everyday bro this
March is seriously the coolest we've
ever had
well I want to sell it like a god Church
if that's possible yeah we got we're
pretty inspired by him kind of I never
saw like a god Church yeah I never saw
like a God or Church did you even sell I
have sold merch
so let's move it on to the next story
Lance Stewart we just post a new video
about Lance Stewart he is the clickbait
god of YouTube and he's been on this
kick he's like a ghost hunter right he
posted this video the scariest night of
my life
which was um a video about how they went
outside a cemetery and played Ouija
board outside a cemetery and the video
was really fake ins and stupid but he
presents it all like it's very hundred
percent real and this one video got a
ton of views and since then his life has
been a total spook fest yeah he's like
oh [ __ ] look at these views and now all
the sudden he's like being haunted he's
being possessed there's demons living in
his apartment [ __ ] like that
and basically it's it he steps it up
every week where I wonder like are every
day where I wonder like he's working
what is left by the way speaking of God
Church the nice thing about it is the
combination of like a paranormal
activity type of like like 200 yeah
yeah like scary videos and then it goes
on to just being a normal vlog at the
same time yeah it's a great combination
that's powerful because you can tell
he's like in a really disturbed state of
mind cuz right after having the scariest
moment his life when he's almost
murdered by paranormal demon he's like
alright guys I'm gonna go hit the gym
now like look at these thumbnails I
almost died and in this vlog literally
nothing happens
a demon attacked me in my sleep with
like Wolverine claws on his back look at
it look at the suffering in his face
he's actually quite talented at that
yeah I mean he's really good at it
natural he's also like just the
straight-up funniest looking guy like he
look he's like so doughy he's like mr.
Potato Head with a little fluff from
paranormal to normal real quick
now this is his new video he just posted
it two hours ago I was possessed actual
footage so look at this thumbnail tell
me if that if you think that is actual
footage from this vlog him on the bed
with his eyes rolled black pearly white
like straight out of the Exorcist or
something so I wanted to watch this
video together with you guys and decide
is this was he actually possessed is
this actual footage let me show ya no
this is fresh content boy I'm bringing
you guys only the freshest memes here
I'm telling you you do not want to miss
this ever so first of all he had this
really traumatic thing he was possessed
by demon but he went back while editing
it and put this in get into the vlog I
wanted to let you guys know that we have
brand new merchandise that just came out
if you guys want to check it out the
link is down below at the very top of
description it's pretty much the summer
line finally releasing the girl products
that you guys have been waiting for as
well as the men's tanky little
soundbites elf completely different like
you can hear all the different times and
sure also we have a beep style that just
came out as well if you guys are it's
like Jesus man
okay [ __ ] just let him go you don't need
to scribe every item there but the point
is like before I tell you the story
about how I almost died today was the
worst day of my life but before that
let's just check out this really brand
new merch it's crazy man here's our new
video recommended on one of his videos I
love that look at this thumb is tunnels
are [ __ ] are interested go to the
link down below at the very top in my
description check it out over there and
get it before these products no Jake
Paul posted my response to the hate I
was wondering if you responded I'll get
that later it's 23 minutes along with
these vloggers needed chill out it's
it's making it really hard for us if we
actually want to make a video about them
and we have to watch their videos for
this hours of content to make sure we're
not missing stuff it's it's got time for
this [ __ ] who needs a 25 minute long
video and then they always clickbait it
like 5 seconds of it
it's bites very nature just garbage okay
like that's why I respect like david
dobrik in a way is his vlogs are four
minutes 20 seconds long and you know he
could should boast a 20 minute video but
he makes great little videos he puts a
lot of effort in the form a point like
he him and lies are the good Viners for
the record yeah those guys are actually
super talented and they're David's are
not exactly just blogs it's kind of like
it's like a vlog sketch yes not even
really a blog kind of like how our
reaction videos aren't really reacting
it's you know I mean it doesn't the the
genre doesn't do him justice but yeah I
really like I think he's talented guy so
it was currently like 6 a.m. and I woke
up I felt a super sharp pain on my back
like something almost like burning like
a burning sensation and I went to go
check in the mirror don't tell me yes
but I'm gonna lose my mind
yes Clark I'm freaking I'm sure you are
Doug
Lizzy please please like record my back
record my back there's something on my
back do you see this on my back don't
you [ __ ] tell me this claw marks dog
I'm gonna lose my mind it looks like
this is the guy I don't know if you guys
have watched our new video but in this
previous video
he basically completely ripped off
paranormal activity and he like green
screened a rope pulling him out of bed
so it looked like he'd been dragged out
like he's taking the stuff to huge
Heights and that's that's him and his
girlfriend by the way as like we're a
couple on YouTube we are yes got him so
they are a couple on YouTube and so I
did I find it funny that together
they're like let's fake this [ __ ] yeah
they're both like crying and like acting
like hamming it up like crazy it's
pretty funny to me I I think they I
think that in their head they're
thinking like we're like the Bonnie and
Clyde of YouTube the ultimate dupe stirs
my sister's yeah they definitely
probably do see them so and it's and
it's true yeah they are man they got all
these 12 year old kids hooked into this
so bad
it burns so bad so let's see it did God
he's milking this [ __ ] so much so anyway
it's like can you imagine waking up and
you actually thought you got clawed by a
demon while you were sleeping
could you honestly go have a regular day
after that in the chat this is porn
acting it is porn acting yeah and it's
kind of similar to you get your like
spooks it's very similar to porn but
here he is underwear shopping make sure
these ones especially smell good
he's looking for good smelling underwear
now can you imagine going shopping at a
Nike store after you got clawed by a
demon in your sleep if you genuinely
believe that shopkin pranksters we've
actually anyway
yeah and they go to the gym and then
they show off their cars yeah it's a
great time so these are the Viner
updates I think we're out of binders to
make fun of which is sad but I had a lot
of fun doing it while it lasted
I feel like Viners were the new
pranksters for us cuz back when we
started YouTube pranksters were like our
muses they were our inspiration yeah cuz
they were blowing up on you to write
another Viners are now the miners are
blowing up and so we've got the blogan
the low gang the jake Pollard's and
Lance Stewart I don't know if there's
anyone left I'm pretty hopeful there
will always be new challenges on YouTube
so let's move it on to more like current
event tea stuff this is kind of like h3
stuff but we have lots of great stuff
here like okay this one happened during
the week and I and I loved it I had a
lot of fun with this one Jerry Seinfeld
Seinfeld one of my favorite shows of all
time
torn to justice I felt is such a goob
though he's like such this great
character he is truly Seinfeld from the
shell in real life which is why I love
the guy so here he is at some awards I
don't know what it is and Ke$ha
Keisha I don't but she comes up and
tries to give him a hug and he doesn't
know who she is here watch this see what
happens it's hard to just sleep when
you're tired because people are tired
most of the time
I don't know who that was guys Kesha
okay like okay so like okay like - Kesha
you're not on Jerry first of all you're
not like you're famous right she's
famous I don't know who she is but she's
famous I've heard the name
there's always someone more famous than
you you're dealing with Jerry Seinfeld
here right and first of all is that I I
feel like that's not a great way to
greet people like what do you think he
was he rude or was that justified
it's just I'm filled Sanfelice iPhone I
don't know how he actually recoils like
she goes in she's like no seriously we
can hug it he's like no no we can't it's
like no he's like he's not leaving a
meme but he's like if you watch the show
and then you see that you can't help but
laugh and enjoy it you know and I mean I
don't feel like he's being rude right I
just mean Jerry Seinfeld yeah but
genuinely in that so [ __ ] like was she
justified and it's going I mean is it
yeah for a total stranger it's Jerry
Simon not just a total stranger you're
talking to Jerry Seinfeld a little
successful artist she's not some like
okay
Rando and his defense presumptuous she's
assuming that Jerry Seinfeld knows who
she is she he's a 60 year old comedian
like it's not exactly a perfect
cross-section - he's in an interview
yeah kind of about high 3 say what up
afterwards introduce yourself then maybe
going froude I don't know yeah but I
love the Jack this cherry is the guy
because on one if that was me and I was
him I would probably not want to hug her
but I would do it anyway because I don't
want but Jerry has that filter where
he's like I am NOT gonna hug you [ __ ]
get the [ __ ] away from me and he doubled
downs on it right I find that
fascinating and I it reminds me of this
other great Jerry Seinfeld clip oh man
watch Jerry Seinfeld on Larry King
very King Live which is another classic
one Jerry just [ __ ] sit along Jerry
just destroys Larry King and I've had
this debate with people - is this just a
fight or not sorry the post-match is
arriving okay
why don't we take a quick break because
I actually need to pee take a really
quick break okay I guess guys don't go
away we're gonna go get the post mates
I'm gonna take a quick break we're gonna
be right back don't go away we have so
many fresh memes on deck if you leave
I'm gonna take I'm gonna burn this
office down for this table and I'm gonna
tear it all down and we'll never have
another episode again all right guys
welcome back guys we are back I was
talking about Jerry Seinfeld when he
tore apart Larry King but when I was in
the bathroom I was taking a piss and I
was like here's something you know it's
never dealt with her girls never dealt
with okay I'm in their paint and a super
tall guy comes and he's next to me and
you feel like they can see your dick
yeah not that you should look now that
they would look and there's not always a
center divider on your way there I don't
understand why don't you have regular
toilets like women do I don't get up
well because yeah well urinals are more
efficient I guess is it yeah cuz you
don't have to touch a door you'd have to
do anything really you just put your
pull your junk out like so old school
why not I love like a tube you just put
your dick in it just sucks the urine out
but I do wonder what what does that feel
like when someone is like standing next
to you is there like a code where you
you shouldn't look like no one looks
yeah you're supposed to look straight
ahead usually just don't look at their
junk either they look look at the wall
yeah it's weird and like the girls are
super close together so usually I don't
even stand that close to people normally
and all of a sudden I'm standing not
only closer to a stranger but we both
have our dicks out how close I mean
really close like almost
shoulder-to-shoulder that's really weird
like really close so there's super-tall
next is so weird yeah that's why it's
not that's why I gets stage fright
there's too many things too
to think about I got this super tall guy
next to me and it looks like if he's
like look you know strange thing here's
another thing if you don't get me
started you go to Dodger Stadium or some
[ __ ] like that they don't even have
stall they didn't have urinals
they have like troughs huge 20-foot long
trucks horses yes it's a long metal
trough and everyone just comes and takes
a piss in it like it's [ __ ] 1500s
medieval dude yeah and it's just it's
absolutely disgusting and then you've
got people like me I guess most dudes
don't care like taking their dicks out
from the other dudes and taking them
piss but then you've got people like me
and everyone's waiting for the urinals
because they're like not comfortable
with that and then you can't pee I can
pee in the urinal no but when you're
like stressed like that yeah when I'm
stressed I can't because I know that
people are waiting and then I worry
again my head like does this dude next
to me does he know that I'm not peeing
cuz he doesn't hear me pain and now you
have a new thing to worry about what's
that do they know you do they know me
that that's new layers yeah that's whole
new layers [ __ ] I just go straight to
the stall at this point in my life I
don't even [ __ ] around the urinals
there's way too much [ __ ] to deal with
their Friday podcast talking about urine
and poop please join us somehow it
always comes back to defecating when I
start talking about [ __ ] that's part of
the show I'm their hitter I just choked
on water I am like a bad drinker do you
relate to that no Christ I do not feel
like half the time I take a drink of
water it goes down the wrong pipe and I
end up choking does anyone out there
relate don't tell me I'm the only one
okay where were we so back to Seinfeld
being a living lay living legend
yeah and against Seinfeld gets in this
situation where it's like it's he
justified or is he being an [ __ ] it's
really fascinating
he's dying Feldman well let's see listen
let's analyze this
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay so here we are get it it's a very
similar situation so they're talking
about Seinfeld and when Seinfeld decided
to stop making the show what it wasn't
only number one on television it's like
the the most probably show I ever made
yeah 75 million people concurrently
watching the final episode that is
mind-bending yeah and so Larry says did
you cancel the show or you can or will
you cancel and it sets him off and I
think understandably and and to give you
guys a little background we're huge fans
of science yeah I loved every episode
made because it's like a real it's it
makes me feel good because I feel like
the show is really authentic because him
and Larry David the co-creator of
Seinfeld and Curb Your Enthusiasm which
is another great show because I'm seeing
it they both deal with these situations
where I think it's so cathartic because
it's like I wish I could do that yeah
but you always take the polite route
like if it was me I'd be like no no we
weren't cancelled that's what Curb Your
Enthusiasm is all about based on that
emotion yeah
so what's he an [ __ ] I don't know he
I don't think so I think it's a I think
he did a great thing for the world know
yeah wasn't a so it was funny
- it was funny it like he was rude he
definitely shamed there's always this
balance of like if you manage to be
funny it's different
mm-hmm if it wasn't funny and be
then you're like yeah this guy's an
[ __ ] yeah that's true that's very
true that's that's a really good point
but I think for all of us out there who
like look back and like I wish I did it
like that when he does he's the guy that
does that give us hope so I tip my being
at a Jerry I love the guy all right
let's move it on what else we got a
great one flat earther you guys probably
heard about this [ __ ]
me neither been trying to make a video
about this Flat Earth [ __ ] for a minute
but I have never really found a good end
it's just honestly so stupid yeah I
don't know maybe people can suggest
stuff for us I don't know like what's
the what's a good video about it that's
worth like what is [ __ ] about Flat
Earth is this theory that I don't know
why they're obsessed why do they care
like what it's this theory that earth
isn't actually a globe it isn't actually
a sphere it's a pancake shaped planet
and NASA and all the world governments
are in a conspiracy together to lie that
space isn't real space is fake they
theorize all of space is fake moon
landing faked anyone who's ever been in
space faked and they even say like when
you're on a plane just look and you see
that it's flat and I filled up is it I
feel like just look and you see that
it's round they always say that right no
I think so you think you can't sleep
curvature yeah a little bit yeah and
they always say like yeah they always
say [ __ ] like that but I'm like no and
then they show like footage from space
that's clearly curved I just don't
understand their theory is that the
whole world government is in a
conspiracy together just to make money
on this space cuz there's so much money
in space I don't know I don't know like
usually like amazing claims like that
need to be backed up with amazing
theories yeah and of the the operation
of faking an entire space faking space
it seems like way too epic of a
conspiracy for just to make money on
spit like it's just a mixed scent like
the conspiracy theory itself is so
disjoint it does not wouldn't be really
crazy if someone actually faked space
but you think would be better for a
better read so much work yes a lot of
work to make like a couple of billion
dollars I don't know like you could pull
they really think that that's it
yes pay I didn't know that I thought
they just thought the earth is flat and
some other stuff like that moon landing
was fine
well the thing it's all connected
because okay I think I'm not however set
on this so don't quote me but I think
they think that no one's ever been in
space every image of Earth or anything
from space has been doctored okay and I
don't know that they think spaces even
exists okay but if you even look at it
from a physics standpoint a flat earth
is literally impossible and in terms of
a physical possibility because if you
when you walk out to the outside of it
is the gravity gets greater yeah it only
works if it's a ball if it's a sphere
gravity only works yeah so I don't know
how they grapple with the theory of
gravity they do a lot of mental
gymnastics and there's even been
theories that these got a lot of them
aren't serious there's a lot of trials
but there's definitely some that are
serious like this guy we're about to
watch Nathan Thompson his whole channel
is just a complete how do you make a
whole channel about it yeah I don't know
the guys like dedicated I feel like when
you go deep deep down conspiracy theory
rabbit holes where everything you do is
dedicate I feel like there's a little
credibility like you can you can pick
one conspiracy theory and dedicate
yourself to that you a UFOs you know
chemtrails that one's a little nutty but
what my point is pick one stick with
that and be saying everywhere else if
you go full conspiracy theory then you
lose a little cred I feel like that's
kinda kind of personality that would go
for conspiracy though if they believe in
one if they believe in one yeah
hmm yeah that's probably well no not
necessarily no not necessarily
you can you can anyway let's watch this
[ __ ] video so this guy he confronts a
NASA employee in Starbucks like the
premise alone thank you giggle alright
guys I'm here with a real NASA employee
legit NASA employee and I asked him I
said astronauts have almost died in
space they get they got water in their
suit and they almost drowned and he said
it was because of saliva this guy right
here hold on I'm gonna wait for him to
get to the front line and then I'm gonna
ask him some more questions there's a
real NASA employee right here first of
all I love that he assumes this random
guy and leather jacket is a legit NASA
employee - so here he's getting on
something about astronauts drowning in
their own suits I don't know what he's
talking about yeah okay probably
something about cuz he thinks it takes
place underwater I honestly don't know
look he was all nice he was all nice he
gave me massa cartoon bringing emblems
gave me NASA flippin cartoon and blurbs
it's called a sticker dum-dum hello
sticker like this is the approach that
these kind of people take instead of
saying sticker
he says NASA cartoon emblem and okay so
the guy gave you a sticker well I guess
we let's keep watch she's like a kid
though he gave me an ice-cream and a
sticker now I won't let me film him
enough Starbucks this guy who's not
actually a NASA employee and is just
getting way too weird for this normal
human being now he won't talk to me
you're standing right next to me can
hear what you're saying you know that
right also by doing this video you're
not gonna you're not helping the
situation no no I mean like look at this
guy nice I'm not talking to me so yeah
right now I'm definitely not gonna talk
to you no but he's gonna get outraged
all the same I guarantee you he won't
talk to me at all sir
just tell them why they almost drown in
space please
come on tell them why they drowned in
space it's like what he's just trying to
get coffee why is he obligated I guess
she's a conspiracy theorist he's this
guy is raping the planet he has made up
this conspiracy about space people are
drowning in space and they're making
like $100,000 every year by this I don't
know he's doing gymnastics and it says
this guy is just a little bit of a weird
um nut himself I feel like he's not
really a NASA employee he's just wearing
that jacket excuse me did you say I hate
Americans it's getting all fired up
Starbucks you guys this is really not
the place for this
and also the god of courage to have
these videos at Starbucks I feel like
Starbucks is like the place interesting
so it creates all this time it's like a
breeding ground yeah I love for the god
of cringe to come just spilled coffee on
himself and join the fray they lie about
everything
this guy it's like I mean that's kind of
a big claim and the sky doesn't seem to
be the most educated or eloquent or
intelligent person on the planet I like
how he's immediately saying you're not
the boss of me
it sounds like a quiet yeah you're not
the boss of me Burton mom I mean bro I'd
have to go to bed till 8:00 thanks for
the NASA emblem cartoon emblem or no he
says NASA flippin and sticker you know
Nessa flippin cartoon emblem that's what
we should start selling emblems
we should start selling h2 h3 flippin
cartoon yeah
well I just got kicked out of Starbucks
for asking NASA employee questions
because he's lying he's a blatant liar
what a joke that was my god what a joke
starting to like get more mad for no
reason all the time that's when I got I
don't think it's poked yeah he's a
little dangerous at this point he's like
a sweet kid but he's little dangerous
he's he needs a she sure like I got
kicked out of Starbucks and all I got
was this cartoon emblem flipping emblem
now we're outside beautiful America man
that was ridiculous of freakin stickers
from the NASA employee guys and then I
start asking him questions he tells me
to go outside of Starbucks I'm freaking
shaking I am shaking I can't believe
that just happened
so Duty clearly a little unstable and
the guy was right there and ask him to
please step away you know be great if a
real NASA employee just to [ __ ] with
this guy's head is like right dad like
they drown because there's no such thing
as space yeah just like get in his head
right I wonder if he uses anything you
can tell this guy did make him happy oh
my lord it's dangerous man nothing like
his levels of angry kids going up not a
good time not a good time know what's
amazing Wow
I just met a NASA employee guys and he
got me kicked out of Starbucks for
asking them questions about astronauts
almost dying in space I said how come
astronauts choked on their hook I make
their most drowning in space you know
what he said he said because they almost
they almost couldn't swallow their
saliva
astronauts aren't trained how to swallow
their saliva in space
I didn't even this is the whole thing is
just too bizarre yeah
Starbucks astronauts drowning and son
their son spit and spit like what the
[ __ ] Doug and emblems emblem spits give
me a freakin break dude he doesn't clip
braid is a curse this guy should be on
stage with Jay Paul you got that Disney
Channel flow hmm give me a break I'm
getting out of here before the police
show up I love you guys good idea um I
don't really uh yeah so I don't really
understand this stuff it's really um
it's just so out there and I and I don't
know what makes them so passionate about
it either because as far as I understand
there's there's no rational backing for
this theory so I don't know why people
are so committed to like what is it do
you think in people's head to make them
go after conspiracy theories like that I
don't know um probably just the fact
that like you can't really trust
anything you hear so I guess for some
people they take it you know really hard
psychologically so you have to start
doubting everything that's interesting
because it is kind of like it comes from
a true place where like even if you hear
something on the news you don't know
right the true story so I think it
probably starts from that but these
people take it like way to that's a
really good point I thought about that
it's like getting paranoid yeah I find I
feel like these days you have an O such
an overload of information it almost has
the opposite effect yeah why politicians
and everyone unlike people on the news
and television can openly lie like just
factually disputable and you have all
these fake news right so it's kind of
like there's so much here's the thing
there's so much information available to
us that nobody has the time or willpower
to actually sort
to say hey this is good information this
is bad information yeah
so it's also chaotic this stuff like
that like this is the extreme result of
that that's interesting I even my
brother was like he told me that all of
a sudden he got into all these videos
about how the moon landing was fake
right and he actually started to like
think about it like maybe it was fake
right but I guess eventually he decided
it wasn't fake but it that's really
interesting I mean there's definitely I
want that's a really unforeseen
consequence I feel like of the
Information Age there's too much
information and also the truth gets like
obstructed in it buried yeah fake news
brave Flat Earth [ __ ] Flat Earth man
alright that was a wild ride absolute
wild journey
let's moving on in yeah Vsauce has a
great video about Flat Earth well yeah
Vsauce yeah that was the one about the
disk right yeah but I think explains the
graph yeah it's a wonderful wonderful
video I mean my opinion he just
completely debunks it using nothing but
actual physics ya know like doctored
photos no oh you can see their horizon
and there's a curvature nothing like
that it's like pure theoretical physics
mm-hmm it should be undisputable it's a
great video should we watch it yeah I
don't think so about watch it in your
free time and checking out that video
for sure oh I do hope you guys are into
this kind of politics but I thought this
was pretty fascinating so Senator John
McCain who ran with Sarah Palin for
president recent like in the past by the
way one of them one of probably the most
colossal political failures ever
probably would have won if he didn't run
with Sarah Palin you remember yeah I
know Sarah Palin Christ
it's crazy like I'm thinking of that
video of her daughter and oh you should
watch that Wow
Pauly D no not the situation yes see
this is like a long thread to pull but I
think you're right we should get into
that we gotta like give you guys John
McCain he's an American Hero
let me just say he found Vietnam he was
a prisoner of war for like years never
gave up any information the guy's
American Hero
it's been in politics for like five six
decades and he almost became president
but he picked Sarah Palin who was a
complete I don't know I don't she just
seems like a really dumb person and I'm
I'm just sick of like super religious
Paul politicians because this is [ __ ]
to me like you enjoy your religion
mm-hmm but this is America that's a
[ __ ] point don't force it on everyone
else don't force it don't mix it at all
that's the whole [ __ ] point mm-hmm I
don't hate you as a Christian I hate I
hate you as a politician who makes it
about your religion that's [ __ ]
that's not what this country is about
and every time I see that like the vice
president Mike Pence
he's so religious he goes he was in an
interview recently where he goes I'm
this thing in an order I'm at first a
Christian I'm second a senator and third
I don't remember third but whatever some
[ __ ] but he but seriously you're
gonna go tell your constituents you're a
Christian first like that's them I don't
know man
that's like his platform he ran on being
a Christian it's [ __ ] I hate it it's
yeah I mean we have the same thing in
Israel where the government is half half
half religious have you know so it's
it's pretty annoying for the people who
are not religious for example on the
weekend the buses don't run and a lot of
times I wanted to I wanted to work on
the weekends and I didn't have a car so
I would have to use the bus but then on
the weekend you don't have a bus so it's
actually like it gets in your way
so so yeah I agree I hate when they
force it on everyone like if you don't
if
you don't want to use it don't use the
bus all right yes I want to use it it's
your [ __ ] choice dog if your religion
doesn't let you use the bus don't get on
the [ __ ] bus but don't try to control
me
but Israel is a theocratic country by
definition it was established a Jewish
state they teach Torah in high school
yeah America was founded as separation
one of the founding tenets separation of
church and state yeah so all the Sun and
I feel like even the founding fathers
you go back there were probably really
devout Christians and they I don't know
you gets like deluded people forget what
it's about you end up with people like
Sarah Palin who are like I'm a Christian
mom with American values than that being
I'm a Christian mom again stabbing and
then all these like really conservative
Christian people who only care about
Christians and other Christian people
are like I'm voting for Sarah Palin
again nothing against Christian pepo I
just hate it in politics I feel the same
way about any religion it's just in
America it happens to be Christianity
that tends to be the one that's like
acceptable yeah I can yeah I agree with
you completely in Israel it's it's a
bigger it's a problem too but at least
they don't pretend like there's a
separation they're upfront about it
right so speaking of Sarah Palin Sarah
was her name Bristol Palin it was with
the situation and and then you have like
so this is Sarah Palin's daughter
basically after their fall from grace
after they lost the election
she's the governor of Alaska and her
daughter like they're these are some of
the most hypocritical people on earth
her daughter is in this video talking
about abstinence only that means do you
know what that is I think you told me
before cuz we were talking about this
video so abstinence only
it's what the the conservatives and
Christians believe should be sex
education which means the only way to
prevent STDs and pregnancy is to never
have sex unless you're married unless
you're married that's the only way they
don't say use a condom
yeah they don't say use the pill they
just say don't have sex that's all
I'm willing to say I'm not advocating
that [ __ ] right here she is in a video
talking about this [ __ ] dummy has to
two kids before the age of 18 by I think
two different dads out of married out of
marriage it's like [ __ ] you seriously it
makes me angry [ __ ] you
practical [ __ ] off dude with this
[ __ ] like if you teach get out of
use condoms and use birth control they
don't get pregnant it's more practical
you can't say someone don't [ __ ] it
clearly doesn't work
she's an evidence of that he was like
calm down I don't like calm down you too
passionate about it makes me upset
because there's nobody use the service
to all society I know like we don't need
you to tell people to not learn about
what they need to learn just giving
people a education yeah sure don't have
sex
oh maybe Austin's here well let me check
my boy is here yeah let's do my god
switch it to the wide we gotta do one of
these like hey hey hey hey like this hey
hey hey hey what TF is up thanks for
coming thanks for having me guys sorry
I'm a little tardy for the party you're
never tardy boy you're right on time ass
you got now follow sorry yeah I just had
to try to spice it up a little today
it's for a new vid I'm working on it but
it's only for myself new video it's only
from it's for my private art
is it better winner jerk-off it's pretty
it's definitely pretty this hot red nice
yet it's nice like I know what you
cherry actually let's take a break then
the middle
let's just stop the podcast right I was
just in the middle of an epic rant about
Sarah Palin's daughter whose teaches
abstinence only education but that [ __ ]
had out of wedlock children twice damn
young and now she's in a commercial and
not have sex it's like [ __ ] you clearly
love it you the sex lover in the you are
you have this problem there's sex crazy
but we we have this a great video that I
just I just love it even if you have
known exactly it's amazing situation and
Sarah Palin's daughter and an
infomercial about safe sex
don't go away I'm gonna take a quick
break so we can get set up with postie
here and make sure the cameras all right
got him we're gonna be back in two
minutes if you leave I will go I will I
will burn the studio down on all these
cameras and you'll never see me again
don't go away we'll be back in just two
short minutes you guys Cheers hey we're
back at a free podcast were joined with
post Malone postie Austin our boy cheers
guys he comes with Bud Lights and
cigarettes where else what else what
else we're outs where outs
I don't know I can't call it am i right
did your you're always right before I'll
let me close this door so last time
Austin actually was the creator of the
spooks spooked sing and goofs I think
you were the first ghost story candidate
where Willy and now every time we have a
guest on it always is like ask him about
the [ __ ] ghost story know that that's
really great well I'm glad that I could
add a new segment to your guy's
repertoire repertoire and dossier if you
will I will if you will I won't
we were just talking about like you
found actual actual haunted place in LA
yeah so it's like in Pasadena it's like
20 minutes away 25 if you book it ever
feats go slow 20 if you book it
I won't organized no oh it's free free
yeah and you can climb down honey
is it organ there's nobody there it's
just a place I haven't seen anybody
there but it's creepy down there did
very creepy here [ __ ] everywhere and
like we so we went down there and we
have it on camera - we caught it we
brought I went with my friends Mike and
Alex they took me down they they showed
me the place like a month ago and I've
been there like three times
oh wow so we went there and we you just
hear like crazy like sticks like big-ass
sticks breaking like Blair Witch yeah
like very Blair Witch II and then you go
down and then there's like it's a dam
and then there's the there's a gate
there and then in the mountain like the
rock you see like the devil's face
that's why it's called Devil's God yeah
and like we heard something like running
at us oh that's so I'm like I'm like in
you know we tried to rationalize it of
course so like we were walking and
there's critters there right well yeah
but a critter wouldn't run at you like
this was like so we we there's like a
hill right here we're in like people
with guns no can we bring yeah I'll just
bring a knife okay nice so good hand
combat yeah bring my spirit gun nice
guys are proven to be more effective
against spirits and poltergeists and
demons and such like that is that a joke
or is that
I mean I'm ready to go hand to hand with
the ghosts I look just keep coming no
matter what happens so and then we were
walking and so there's a hill here in a
fence and on the other side of a fence
it was like like running running towards
us I look we book the [ __ ] out but it's
just you guys yeah there it was it was
four people
how far you from your car it's far walk
it's in Pasadena it's called The Devil's
Gate we should go yeah we should go so
but I figured you know a critter
wouldn't run at you and a critter
wouldn't be that big unless it's like
probably human sized right sort of or
Jaguars something I don't think there's
any man-eating probably one kangaroo
exactly he just wants everyone but he's
not even alive kangaroo he's a spirit he
died there so Austin wants to take us to
make a video there oh my god I'm scared
you guys have a night-vision cam yes we
just got a new one it's got infrared got
him maybe we'll pick up some heat
signatures oh my god okay well we have
to do it so I had a paranormal
experience mm-hmm we talked about it
last episode but it was deep in so I'm
gonna call it again so yeah I'll tell
you the Reader's Digest there so we were
in our bedroom in our camera sorry we
got a new setup doesn't look great
[ __ ] we finally got it figured out
man and we got our up our internet
working so lightning fast
what's the upload downloads like the
upload is like yeah it's more expensive
how can I have that Alex for no reason
yeah it's not-- they just charge you
more cuz your business well you use are
you at liberty to disclose that yeah at
home we use time owner I find them both
to be to be good mine sucks
really yeah I'll be it takes me a whole
day to download an Xbox one hold you
have the best internet
yeah but you know up in my house you
didn't have no signal but we do have so
I'm thinking for this next one that's
true
did you get Internet there ya know I
told my guys to set it up but you're
probably getting there there that area
is a little funky ya know it's like dark
zone we almost missed our flight because
we couldn't get a hold of you I should
go back now you have congratulations on
the new house by the way thank you
that's really [ __ ] awesome
can we get so anyway I was telling
Austin the last time you were here that
we've never had a paranormal experience
and I'm super skeptical of all this [ __ ]
mm-hmm so we're in our room it's 3:00
a.m. I'm laying a bet I've like a really
bad headache and I noticed there's like
a really strong red running drip running
it was dry but it was a big drip that
had run down the wall from where I don't
know like in the middle of the water
later I was on the wall in a really
weird place where we're never there
there's no way we splashed we're never
there and I sister eulah jokingly I says
why is our wall bleeding right I'm like
what the [ __ ] and I walk over to it and
it looks like dried blood look at that
damn randomly show that here let me show
that show yeah here I'll hold it up
that's strange right it's like looks
like drag it's just y'all it's just me
Neela no one ever comes in our bedroom
like so it that you know yeah that we
know right hey guys I don't know it's
like a drape on the wall let me show you
just to make sure you guys do this right
and then zoom in on it so you can see
the drip like that's it it's a really
bizarre
doesn't it case it looks like Albemarle
it'd be cool Albemarle just one little
drop it's artsy so I'm like how the [ __ ]
right did this get here and I start
actually getting spooked for 10 minutes
cuz I'm like this is really bizarre like
there's no explanation right of this and
then I take a closer look at I'm like
well actually that's more Brown than red
so is Dookie I'm like what and then we
remember there's like a route like the
biggest moth I've ever seen trapped in
our room and they were like oh [ __ ] and
it was on that side of the wall were
like this is just mouth
it has to be a giant mouth shut and I
was like a what it was I'm sure was a
giant [ __ ] but I was like smelling it
the gun it tested
it was brown when I looked closer it was
close to I was a closer the dark MA
fades of death VI was almost patient
zero
STD I'm so anyway that was our story but
I was like I was pretty spooky man
you're gonna get spooked down here it's
real spooky spooky so anyway let me
bring you up to speed
okay so we're doing this episode called
top of the month okay where we bring
together all of our favorite little news
stories and memes that we collect
throughout the month okay and right now
we were talking about you know Senator
John McCain he was at the Comey hearing
the FBI director okay and he had like us
he like couldn't talk I don't look like
he was having a stroke on camera it was
really sad he's completely senile I
don't I don't think he had a stroke but
he was like completely incoherent so
then we got into this thing about
crystal Palin because he looks for him
Kristen he was running with Sarah Palin
and then I got into this whole thing
about them so we're following the threat
so this is crystal Palin and the first
old Palin tell me about safe sex with
the situation so let's have a look here
damn shouty
well excuse me miss have you ever had a
situation with the official situation
that's pretty like him he's horny I
don't know okay I find it he's willing
to portray himself like that he's horny
he gets from one bed to another no
hesitation I love usage just as a
precursor I love the city Palin
everybody knows me those words don't
work I got the situation that jewelry by
the way it's very vampires Wow very
vampire ass garlic on this good old
vampire outfit is very vampire it is
right you looking for this suit was
black and Mike had contacts in or
something oh yeah and just like there's
like industrial rave music playing be
right out of like come on be Palin you
serious like you're not gonna hook up
with like before you manic for real for
real for real for real for real for real
and just to give context she's actually
had two kids already out of marriage and
she what does he did deny it no she's
just like I made a mistake but all you
guys out there don't have sex but wait a
minute
is when how old is this this is from
2010 okay so see she's saying here how
older kids maybe she had a kid right
with the situation it was successful
Chris Palin
hmm oh my god
this is from December 2016 Bristol Palin
says she's pregnant with a third child
what a stupid hypocrite shut up wait
wait
third child so and she saves that she's
not gonna hook up until marriage is she
married Rayna no I think all of them
were out of wedlock does it say that mr.
pan the Sarah Palin daughter almost as
famous his mother thanks to
unconventional domestic history says
she's pregnant with her third child yada
yada yada whatever not that interesting
but she has three kids she's married now
but she definitely had it anyway
whatever whatever [ __ ] her okay I get it
right am i right about that
am i right situation I want to make sure
that you are situated because if you do
get into a situation with your situation
you may end up with a situation and you
may not like that situation damn no it's
great content
no wonder if he wrote that or they had
like a room of writers but yeah I mean
just winging it and say make sure the
people know who you are we need okay
situation it's like meow is from Super
Troopers Yeah right yeah situation
situation we just see how many times he
can fit it in see where his record is
such a run-on you know what I totally
respect that and I totally respect
abstinence I mean actually has the word
absolutely stop dude with the situation
cheerio we get it [ __ ] very funny but
I'm worried about you cuz I've had three
[ __ ] kids abstinence-only shut up
best deal
am i right I'm worried I'm worried about
you situation no have no kids right
that's right situation doesn't have kids
which exactly which method works better
condoms are not funny statistically I
actually practice a whole lot I mean a
whole lot the safe part we got the same
part down what pal magnums stuff I got
him got him yeah she definitely smashed
and why is she wearing that fabulous
outfit I'm looking at more fabulous
outfits you know when he puts on that
Magnum condom he probably like puts his
balls into it and [ __ ] he's got so much
space you know supposed to put the balls
in I'll try that just buy the biggest
one you can find
it's probably like it's a balloon he's
probably when he puts on a magnum it's
probably like throwing a hot dog through
the Lincoln Tunnel or some [ __ ] about
his situation this water that's my
situation guy it is a situation it is it
is the type of [ __ ] yeah I want to know
what this situation is though let's find
out more I might be able to spare one I
mean you know it's fine Yeah right good
good if you're good in voiding
situations and you're situated and I'm
situated situations under control
can we [ __ ] stop with this [ __ ]
it's so too many situations sorry I
don't think you never have enough
situation is that good branding the
situation like this way do you guys need
a name yeah like that you could just say
the 40 times in one sentence
that's who quit the Bradbury
but see the situation can be brought up
at the moment I'm the moment let's get
situated I just had a moment like
situating about to have a moment a
moment
hold on baby about the last amendment
we'll have a moment I'm having a moment
here
but as you know I am the moment I'm
welcome just let you know I'm the moment
we're gonna have a moment
I'm the moment doesn't sound like a real
word anymore
the moment moment moment moment moment
moment I think about Oh actually give me
a moment you can't do that see it has
more application in this situation can't
say can I have can I have a moment
please
yeah that's true I think moment is a
broader yeah situation I'm the moment I
like that
back off stitch it's me the moment I'm
the moment I'm the mom we agree on one
thing
pause before you play pause before you
play that's probably the most important
thing you got to think before you get
into a situation PB y P that ain't no
PB&J sandwich
sighs Adam at the end just so you know
you know he was like alright I'll do
this spot but I need to make sure that
I'm wearing Magnum condoms I need people
to know exactly that that's the
situation in this moment right now I
mean I liked it well it was kind of a
nice message because they're like listen
we have different thoughts we have
different philosophies on this but let's
all take a moment right take a moment
and situated pause before you play it
exactly okay that was like the worst
preload but anyway so now this is John
McCain questioning James Kony
Wow in the case by the way I think we
need to take a moment through just what
happened he had a moment yeah can we
just acknowledge at least that like how
what a crazy time we're living in here
like this is some Renaissance oh [ __ ]
you have the director of the FBI former
director testifying against the
president like in 50 years people will
be talking about this I don't know yeah
it looks like it looks like it's a full
house a school story time at school
it does but grown people I doubt it's
usually that full this is like a
momentous occasion here this is really
something Clinton you made the statement
that there wasn't sufficient evidence to
bring a suit against her although it had
been very careless in their behavior but
you did reach a conclusion in that case
that it was not necessary to further
pursue her yet at the same time in the
case and mr. Comey you said that there
was not enough information to make a
conclusion tell me the difference
between your conclusion it's a pretty
much ward's out and he refers to him he
calls him president Comey like twice
throughout this he's like genuinely
confused and then he says he's talking
about him and like the third person he's
like and you referred to mr. Comey it
was used he's talking to he's genuinely
having a moment it's kind of sad
actually well he's all this Huck yeah
what he can't lift his arms up what does
that mean cuz he was tied up and are you
serious I didn't know that so he can't
lift his arms
I like no I I said before you got here
he's an American Hero right the guy is
an absolute American legend but no it's
sad to see it's just it's interesting
it's kind of a fascinating thing so you
goddamn buddy
former Secretary Clinton is concerned
and and mr. Trump the Clinton
investigation was a completed
investigation okay
anyway this goes on for a minute but
like the size of July the food gets it's
it's quite sad to see you know for sure
it's fascinating at the same time like
such a fall from grace for in a way but
so what's gonna happen with this whole
thing
yeah you think what's going on with with
our I don't know I really don't know
because everyone's so polarized like
conservatives don't think it's a big
deal Democrats think it's a huge deal
but in this testimony Comey says that
there's meetings there was meetings yes
he said Trump lie is lying he said the
FBI director I mean he's kind of a
reputable person right he served under
mmm several presidents under both
parties and why did he get fired Donald
Trump fired him according to coma
because he was investigating refreshes
right and that's what he says right here
and during this testimony that's [ __ ]
crazy
he says they believe this [ __ ] is still
going on well it's because it's like
you're falling down the rabbit hole and
you don't know how far it goes right but
he says like Trump asked him to pledge
loyalty to him I read that he says that
he he says that he asked him to drop the
investigation altogether and in a
private meeting and what did call me say
call me said that Trump asked him to
drop the investigation and what did can
we do did he drop it no no no no he
didn't it's still ongoing what's
happening
it was covering his face tighten it up
you up you having a moment or a
situation anyway whatever [ __ ] this [ __ ]
but [ __ ] crazy it is crazy it's crazy
I mean in like I know what is that is he
impeached and then charged with treason
it's which is wonderful by death can you
imagine if Trump is just executed it
would be crazy that would be a plot
twist that would be quite a twist he's
not been impeached he's not been charged
with anything but like keeps getting
deeper it's crazy like he probably
wouldn't be charged he'd probably be
just being paged because I mean that's
pretty heavy-duty stuff to charge like
even Nixon who was actually right would
have been impeached and he you know you
okay you need help okay
he was acquitted he wasn't charged for
anything I think it's too way too
traumatic for the country to actually
because there's people the super
president yeah kill mmm we have to
believe that I'm not saying one side of
the others right I'm not like staking it
right you saying it's really fascinating
things so polarizing - it's [ __ ]
crazy let's get let's get off that
people lose their mind when we talk
about politics did you see the new video
he posted a new video we just watched it
already
deema attack in my slave he did it's
really nothing he just wakes up and
there's like scratches on his back and
he's like I'm [ __ ] oh hell yeah boy
click farm crazy yeah doesn't think
people know what's you exposed him real
nice well his videos are getting like
double the views as usual his channels
blowing up because it was paranormal
[ __ ] wow what a plan we G bored and then
from then on capitalize on being alright
I mean I have to give the guy credit he
really is - clickbait
Master seriously I'm never ready for it
before this let's not forget his
girlfriend yeah she's all together
she's like a Lady Macbeth yeah Black
Widow alright so here is another video
this is an oldie but I found I saw it on
reddit today and I was absolutely
fascinated by it for context Trump is
getting a lot of [ __ ] right now and a
lot of his supporters again not taking
sides or saying the president's getting
way too much [ __ ] it's a bunch of bull
freakin baloney and it's just not right
and I stumbled upon this clip of Fox
News criticizing Obama well you just
can't this is wonderful you gotta see
for yourself you do have to see for
yourself but if this just proved that
like everyone needs to chill the [ __ ]
out
exactly everyone needs to chill the [ __ ]
out
stop thinking they're the victims
everyone's absolutely out of their mind
[ __ ] this is a clip from Fox News
Sean Hannity during the same point in
Obama's presidency as we are now in
trouble let's see what they're
criticized its mustard so watch this I
was shocked mustard sucks
I would never be mush on my hamburger
you [ __ ] didn't put ketchup on a
steak or something oh that was a thing
that they were that he says buy a $50
steak and puts ketchup on CNN tonight
okay okay so but I mean it's just runs
imperfect so perfect so this is a
perfect parallel condiments do not make
the man condiments don't make the man
that's I think everyone needs to
remember that as you all know President
Obama is a real man of the people and
yesterday he dropped by a popular
Virginia restaurant too pointed out that
plain old ketchup well it didn't quite
cut it for the president plain old
ketchup didn't quite cut it from our
president who's a praise apparently a
president of the people well why is he
putting mustard on his hamburgers then
breaking news it's like how the [ __ ] do
you ever take me so seriously loser
they're just saying that he's too bougie
yes but we'll keep watching he doesn't
ask for for like what is it poop on poop
on Grey Poupon what the [ __ ] now take a
look at him ordering his burger with a
very special condiment
[Music]
medium-well Wow really president playing
a little safe there do you think [ __ ] I
see monsters yes for DeJong yes spicy
mustard Heinz makes a Dijon mustard what
a bitch-ass president what does that say
about the the hamburgers he said or
something like that they have it what no
I was saying he even said or something
like that I'm open options I am the
president I could make you but go get it
deep my sincere apologies for that
that's crazy though don't watch just a
little bit too much television as a kid
I don't recall him asking for Grey
Poupon no either you know these guys
doing like a sandwich drug deal that's
true yeah they try they're trying to
like make a conspiracy theory out of it
like oh [ __ ] Obama's in on this Grey
Poupon conspiracy this is like YouTube
filler status like you're rolling a
whole commercial it's like yes we all
remember the Grey Poupon commercial you
don't need to show me the whole [ __ ]
thing Sean Hannity yeah just trying to
meet that 22 minute mark all right I
hope you enjoyed that antsy burger mr.
president like this day is just proof of
how [ __ ] this country is like everyone
is so outraged
everyone's so pissed off it's not just
the Democrats about Trump this is when
Obama was president they were
criticizing the man for putting [ __ ]
mustard on his hamburger this is just a
public service announcement
for everyone to chill out okay like
christ almighty man it's completely
blown away by that that's a great that's
a great fine yeah forget Obama got a lot
of [ __ ] yeah oh yeah this whole thing
like they were saying he wasn't an
American citizen that that birth
certificate [ __ ] I mean that was a
nightmare for him yeah how do you
imagine Bhama must have reacted seeing
this [ __ ] like [ __ ] coming at
me if we're putting mustard on my burger
you study the journal pediatric you roll
with Mountain Dew god bless you too oh
we hadn't we already had a spell once do
we need to clean up I can't have to pee
should we take another break this is
like a break filled I mean all right
let's do it guys
don't leave if you leave I will burn
this place down I will kill myself and
he'll it'll be a double homicide murder
suicide it'll be all over the news
you'll never see me again don't leave
because we're just getting started we
have tons of spicy videos left hope you
enjoy your fancy P smoke the whedon
they're coming in the studio all since
having a real intimate conversation now
who do we got on the phone let's put
them up to the speaker what album is
that
I need to listen I do need to listen to
more mm so guys we have um Ellis brother
and mom joining us this is getting weird
wild we're not on the record officially
but we're chilling wait is that Justin
Bieber Oh what up Doug you probably
don't know who I am but that's crazy are
the best singer in the world I think
that you I think that you have a
beautiful ABS oh yeah I think he's got a
situation you have the greatest smile I
think you have a beautiful soul and I
think that a lot of people look up to
you and you make the world a better
place
that was really beautiful sure I love it
it's a nice moment I love you more baby
I'm gonna call you up to this podcast hi
Padma be safe okay get some sleep okay
holy [ __ ] I thought that was one of your
Bros from back I didn't realize those
[ __ ] Justin Bieber I was like who the
[ __ ] is this guy on the phone well cut
that out of the final I leave it in that
was a nice home that was a beautiful
moment I can't believe that was just
bugging what the hell I hope I didn't
like say anything really no that's okay
no it's fine that was a beautiful
that was completely unexpected I thought
it was one of your dogs
my dogs can't speak English wow that was
really nice follow that that was a
really special I love that with a Titan
ham [ __ ] with the president put in
muscle I wonder if Justin Bieber puts
mustard on his burgers damn I should
have asked him he does have the best abs
he's got abs in the game he has a crazy
situation going on that was insane well
everyone who left I warned everyone who
left that they were gonna miss some good
[ __ ]
I said don't leave there's great [ __ ]
ahead damn 2,000 people left and they're
[ __ ] missed it damn damn well so
we're expecting Ellis Wow there's just
surprises throughout Wow wait you lose
parents are coming her mom and brother
wow this is big this is a big deal this
this episode has a lot of surprises a
lot of you never know what you're gonna
get on the yeah I looked in the chat and
they're like it's Justin Bieber I was
like oh [ __ ] I can't type on here I
tried to type to people and it wouldn't
let me how come I don't know just some I
can't login as if it's okay it's cool I
didn't know anything I didn't have
anything constructive to say anyways
excuse me sorry sorry accept our
apologies on that the merch by the way
it's banger isn't this shirt grey it's a
great shirt like they just made this
design look great represent com4 slash
h3 h3 it's fire thank you you're right
where were we damn and you got the new
gear too
yeah look at the back but they made that
it's pretty sweet right super sick you
look blaze nothing I do look blaze they
definitely gave me the red I know what
they're doing exactly ok let's move it
on it's hard to move on past that let me
let me just tell everyone
don't work what happened I was trying to
login okay I was just saying not luck
then my mom came here for the first time
by herself it's the first time she's
ever traveling by herself that's wild
ever Wow by yourself yeah she's been
married since she was 18 so now she like
beer
the old ball she might can I kick it yes
you can can I kick it that's a moment
that's that's a moment you just had a
moment I had a moment it was very deep
breathes
sensual Wow so yeah she's coming here
with my brother go you brother luscious
locks yeah oh yeah really beautiful here
no log well blocks means long flowing
hair - dreadlocks okay yeah you can have
beautiful locks it looks like Jesus
yes very power he's actually been Jesus
National Geographic really marries Wow
like he moonlights as you and and
interestingly his name is Moses that's
crazy it's kind of fascinating it's like
a Moshe in Hebrew but what means Moses
yeah he goes by Moses here yeah all
right let's move it on to actually let
me let me get back on the record here
although I guess we can start make sure
it's cool with Biebs
I don't want it be cool to include a
face down but if not then we'll cut it
off because it was an intimate moment
okay we're back with some more videos on
deck it's hard to follow up that mustard
hard to follow the mustard but we're
back on Fox News but this time we're not
goofing on them Tucker Carlson
interviews this social justice where who
says don't say breast feeding is natural
because it discriminates against women
who don't want to breastfeed it's a
really great journey into the
aniss of social justice warriors right
and the the I wouldn't want to say the
regressive left the radical left it's
really great clip listen listen let's
take a dive tricks describes it as quote
unethical to call breastfeeding natural
because doing so might undermine
feminism the study says quote coupling
nature with motherhood can inadvertently
support biologically deterministic
arguments about the roles of men and
women in the family
Catherine that is just such stupid crap
all right is this the same guy the
burger guy no but they all look the same
everyone at Fox's is like the generic
whitest person in Atlanta isn't that
like a bunch of news casters and they
all look alike and they're all white
people Fox News here these are all the
Fox News anchors Wow is that the whitest
thing you've ever seen I just want to
show this picture they just throw do
didn't like three dudes at the end I was
thinking of doing a painting of this
once that's why I looked at this picture
look at the great painting you know when
you take a while yeah you know when the
people make mosaics of like little
images like these are the white parts
never even thought about that look at
all that anyway so regardless what did
she say like it's unethical to say
breastfeeding is natural but it is it is
that's the problem this is what I can't
stand your art your bidding your
slamming your head against the wall
they'll argue that like Green is orange
or like that's even more subjective
these people but it's like you are you
bored bored I mean that's got to be
trolling it has to be this lady's real
as a heart attack is she in the video
yes
this is a great theory was a journalist
and publisher of Catalina magazine Joyce
she's all got a puckered lips she's
already a yes she's already like yeah
[ __ ] said she's boring hey thanks for
having me so this was kind of a baffling
story one that people are inserting
politics into breastfeeding which seems
like he's not here to [ __ ] make
friends with her this is the segment
we're like let's bring this dum-dum on
[ __ ] him up on TV why it would be
controversial to call breastfeeding
natural if if breastfeeding is not
natural what is natural what
breastfeeding doesn't come naturally as
pediatricians will tell you it's not
exactly easy there elect Asian
specialists out there there's a whole
industry out there doesn't mean it's not
natural
right it's maybe some women have trouble
breastfeed yes it just doesn't work
really yeah some women can have a baby
and they just can't breastfeed like my
sister she had a baby and she tried it
like during the first week was there no
milk or the baby wouldn't latch Wow okay
what happens in nature sitting does the
baby just starve it seems really well I
guess back in the day they had they had
what they called wet nurses they had
women who are always lactating that they
could throw their baby on the tip you
need a tip for the baby but clearly very
natural I mean even like animals every
mammal breast feeds as part of what
being a mammal is you have a tit and
milk comes out and the baby sucks in its
nutrients it's natural it's it's
triggering yeah it's figuring
breastfeeding isn't exactly natural
doesn't come naturally to women so what
they're saying is which I'm so happy
there's a study out there that are
finally letting women not have this
guilt trip that it's okay to
in the formula so this is this is the
problem they're making this argument so
broad so blunt
she doesn't want hand breastfeeding is
not natural and it's just screaming
already say that and then she says some
women can't lactate fine it's not
they're not the same point yeah and then
she's talking about it's okay to handle
the formula to daddy but it's fine yeah
however it's a Barak it's strictly a
prerogative yeah exactly
it's the same way that lead they're like
deal are you triggered
I've been triggered before but this is
the problem like I've always identified
as a progressive liberal person but more
and more every year I find myself
completely confused about my like
political identity because if these are
people on the Left I just think they're
that they're they're turning to like um
do you like censoring people they're
trying to control what people can say it
like pronouns and shits it like I don't
know the whole thing is like you it's
too far it's too far they take it way
too far way too far like in Canada like
this whole thing that happened what was
the name of that guy Jordan Peterson
this whole thing that happen in Canada
they passed a law that says if somebody
wants to be called a pronoun you have to
buy a lot so if you have a woman who
wants to be called he because she
identifies as a man it's illegal to not
call her by the pronoun she wants I
don't know I don't know the details but
that's crazy that was even written up
right I mean I'm all for everybody you
know doing whatever they want to do or
force you by a law like if you're like
please call me he and I keep calling you
a sheet that maybe might make me an
[ __ ] but that's my [ __ ] right to
be an [ __ ] don't put me in jail
because I didn't call you a he [ __ ] you
fine it did pass god help Canada god
help them all I need to help the world I
need to look in that if that's actually
a long can I
we're losing Western society I genuinely
think that if we've come to the point
that is truly depressing wow that's
truly depressing so what does anybody
know the consequence yeah what is it
what am I gonna get it it's yeah it kind
of comes from the same angle because
like if you go to it is Islamic world a
Muslim Arab country and they're like
women have to cover themselves or women
can't drive it's almost it starts to
tread on the same territory of personal
liberties full circle back to perimeter
right or you know I think that if you're
a religion and you don't want a woman to
drive and you're a woman you don't want
to drive because you want to serve their
religion great right
but if once you start passing laws to
proced rig people's personal freedoms
then we're just going back in time my
friends back to tyranny yes that's
exactly right we're gonna have a
situation this is turning to a real man
to feed a baby so they're saying that
only a woman able to feed a child is is
inappropriate it's unethical and
inappropriate and I'm so nobody says
that nobody ever says that men have been
feeding babies forever you just said it
yourself
it's natural she serves this issue of
like men somebody says it's unnatural
for a man to feed a baby I don't think
anyone says that we don't make milk out
of our boobies that's clear so if you
want to breastfeed if I mean it all is
up to the parent it's all an option of
the parents do you wanna breastfeed or
do you want to take turns giving formula
I mean if a down to let the baby suck on
my hairy tip I promise you that if
that's what she wants I'll give it a
shot
fine I mean it's not unethical or
inappropriate whatever those words mean
I mean it can it's the opinion of some
physicians that breast milk is superior
to formula and other people disagree and
that's a it's a debate that is raged for
quite some time but it's what your seem
to be saying is
it is bad because it suggests that women
have a different role in motherhood than
men do but would they do because women
are the only people biologically capable
of bearing children is that now a
controversial observation well it's not
birth childbirth is not natural anymore
like he's I mean he's really approaching
it right yeah I mean that's a great
argument are we are we come to the point
where birthing a child is not
conservative female thing right I don't
know like this whole thing with gender
identity it's like if I have a dick I'm
a man by birth that's what it is
I can cut it off or I can identify as a
female but I have a dick I was born a
man
that's my gender it's wild it's it's
weird cuz they come from like good
intentions right you know the idea is
good but they take it so far and becomes
like bad
it's a tyranny of thought when you're
trying to control what people can say
and think like let's have a debate about
let's talk about I'm interesting you're
in your philosophy I mean well you know
like I said I'm all down for everybody
doing whatever they want to do if you
want to be a woman and you're a guy go
for it god bless you know but it's like
I if you get upset because you know
someone doesn't like quote unquote
understand how you feel about being
called a man or a woman or something or
like just [ __ ] like that what do you
expect like what do you want us to do
like we don't know anybody yeah yeah we
don't know whether to call you what you
want to be called or if we say one thing
you're gonna get offended you know what
I mean so that like to the whole
Canadian and I think use the pronoun
that and the situation is like
compassion and understanding right you
can't make a law making a lot to force
people to do a certain way it doesn't
create understanding right it just
creates more fiction creates more
problems makes people hate you more yeah
and it's like you like doing that thing
like if you get a gender change or
something you already know that it's
gonna be different like you don't you
already know that you might get [ __ ] for
it yeah you know but it's like we
don't know how to handle it because
we've never been in that situation
before right it's a new thing it's new
it's a new thing and it's even new to
them yeah I I feel for transpeople I do
they have like really high suicide rate
really had to pressure rate they go
through a lot of [ __ ] yeah and I and I
totally relate and I have compassion for
those people but like and I think a lot
of trans people are very reasonable
about it I think it's just like this one
was not trans like I mean I don't know
the people who causing all the outrage I
almost don't even represent the
disenfranchised in a lot of ways they
make it worse for them right yes
broadcasting that don't resonate with
right with I don't know if that's true
but I assume it is I have to do you
think she breastfed she probably made
her husband put on one of these things
where you have like fake tits and the
model comes to the nipple the only ones
who could feed the children so that's
what they're trying to say it is natural
for Tuesday I love this who's they feed
the children isn't the idea of baby
formula to replicate breast milk yes I
know though because like parents they
always take yeah that's what I'm saying
in modern society even even can you mix
it up like so why can't if the mom wants
to do breast fed and then if she did the
dad wants to feed him why could you
think it too reasonably
yeah I'm waiting way to reasons but
she's saying right she's saying
reasonable things with it she's like
it's unethical and then it's like what
but that's nobody thinks that she goes
they think it's unethical it's like no
the whole burden is not on the mother so
that's what they're trying to say what I
love that the biggest the biggest like
there's two people talking and then the
biggest square
like we know it breastfeed guys like we
don't need this huge stock photo with
lady put a tip okay first of all of
course that's true of course and I don't
think women are stupid had a mother that
had a child starving for two weeks she
was not able to lactate she was not able
to produce two weeks the baby had lost
weight and she refused to give that baby
formula yeah that lady's a dumb [ __ ]
she's a stupid person she's
irresponsible she's dumb
what does that have to do with anything
it's one person she should yeah she's
just formal I think that's a universal
right conclusion it's just like
necessity is I wouldn't say the mother
of invention but in this case it's the
mother of not kissing you baby some
people couldn't breastfeed so then
there's a safe alternative that actually
works and gives the baby nutrients that
it needs in her world men are like you
cannot give that baby formula you must
breastfeed because that's your role as a
woman and it's and you have to because
she's probably talking about like two
people I have never heard anybody I go
anything close to that
it's like I don't know I don't know how
he deals with this because it's like
just nonsense for fear look at this face
although I saw me and where he has that
face in every single interview mouth it
really is the focal point of his face
too it's just like probably put some
mustard on his burgers milk and we'd
have to turn to formula that's a totally
fair point and that's a shame when
people feel like perhaps there are some
but that's not what's really going on
here this is gender politics intruding
on the personal decisions that it
parents make it's also blurring the
lines it's suggesting by the way that
men can breastfeed which I don't think
they can I don't think they can I like
it does it sour
we've come to the point where we
actually have to be like 10 min
breastfeed you might have a situation I
don't know did you know they can't
breastfeed you know but you guessed it
[ __ ] you guess they can't breastfeed
it's like no this is not a debate let's
not debate if men can breastfeed this is
the problem how far back do we have to
debate these things milk doesn't come
out my dad no matter how hard I try I
guarantee it I'm for children I can tell
you she like doesn't trust him to watch
this she's I gotta know your secrets are
maybe there's [ __ ] maybe you're not
trying hard enough concede the point
that men can't breastfeed please just
for the world did you could you imagine
like the wife leaves it's like watches
out to the windows I see that she's
actually gone and he just tries to it's
like when you jerk off when everyone
will use Shh you gotta wait a couple of
minutes to make sure they're actually
gone and I didn't leave something at the
house I don't that's against God I have
breast fed i breastfeed ela she's in the
word say no you can feed children
they're finally putting a study out
there that's saying that breast milk is
not the only way to go there are other
ways you're dodging what I'm saying look
strictly speaking I don't disagree with
you but the debate thank you thank you
that's nice if I see Warren she's like
yeah god I'm gonna say something
indisputable men can also feed babies of
course of course
also loving a child is natural wait love
is natural don't don't push that I'm
really sorry I'll push that shummy you
[ __ ] communist you're not see me
breast milk is better or worse than
formula and again that is a scientific
debate that nutritionists and physicians
can have this is feminist group saying
how dare you suggest that it's bad dear
women to feed babies because that
somehow ties them biologically to the
act of procreation and my only point is
feminists as usual are helping to
obscure biological realities because
they don't like them and that's an
attack on science it's a study that's
just saying it's inappropriate to say
that breast milk is the only natural way
to feed a child a man could naturally
feed a child in other way I mean like
how yeah I mean technically it's not
it's not necessarily I don't think it's
natural for form to use formula it's not
it's a replication of something that's
actually not it's like technically it's
just not natural focusing on the word
like with matter like is it it doesn't
matter yeah like just because you're
using all natural baby formula doesn't
mean that it's human-made natural if you
go back boobies are making milk like
that's that's a fact that's a fact and
if you go back to him where we live in
caves there was no [ __ ] baby formula
and that was the man supposed to feed
the child yeah you know a hunter
hunting-gathering
look at her face but she looks she looks
zonked that's the face of modern
feminism there she is
Cathy I read you get a look at that huh
eyes a little too wide it's a little too
wide something happens when you join the
cult about race where your eyes get it
like it's tried to get like bigger and
bigger that's when you know it's like
the zombie apocalypse and they like they
like look for like bloodshot eyes or
something you've been infected that
highs are getting wider a man can't
naturally feed a child
naturally give it formula natural it's
the natural loving if natural like
saying that it's wrong
weed saying that it's not natural yeah
no one's saying that it's wrong of
course that's why the conversation is so
confusing she's talking about semantics
right and she's just confusing the whole
issue was just ridiculous it's a dumb
pointless conversation that shouldn't
even take place especially on national
television oh yeah yeah they was a good
TV can you just take three steps back
there's something pretty awful about
inserting gender politics into something
as beautiful and intimate as the first
days of a child's life not beautiful it
causes so many headaches and it could be
so horrible I mean why is she talking
like universally when everybody yeah
breastfeeding is not beautiful right
sorry you had a bad experience with it
he wouldn't understand though cuz he's
he's a man yeah he would never run you
couldn't possibly chime in on that let
me speak for all women right now by
saying that breastfeeding is not natural
right it's disgusting and it sucks and I
hate it
but he is essentially taking away the
beauty of a child
get some milk under there man
you don't think any mom has it as I yeah
well probably for the emotional
connection but I've heard a lot that
it's probably painful it really depends
you can have a completely different
experience but I can imagine that it's
probably very spiritual like very like
instead of something from someone else's
from your own baby suck in your bid for
life for life not for like the length of
life just force us to yeah it's a
beautiful thing because we're so we as
humans are so removed from that like
actually being animals for being like
primal that whenever you actually get
like
I know if [ __ ] out a baby and having
it suck on your tit like that's as close
as we get to actually being like cavemen
animals right we're so removed from the
whole experience of just being animals
it's kind of a beautiful thing I think I
don't know you're not see we'll try when
we have a baby I'll try and see where
I'll film it and put on YouTube real
baby help came out of my nipple question
mark question mark really help
breastfeeding apostrophes you're gonna
want to see this it doesn't come
naturally for so many women so this
study I think it's wonderful because
women could finally step back just know
it's okay to hand the bottle and the
baby over to dad yes half of that
sentence is correct of course it is
absolutely okay to do that thank you but
I'm just thankful thank you I love how
she's like thank you thank you you you
understand now you get it thank you and
for you because this is giving you a
little bit of a headache I'm so
offensive just so crazy
to breastfeed how did like the species
get to where it is now like what a good
question several millennia ago I think
we found other ways like formula to feed
the babies formulas but a rough like
maybe 80 years
cavemen that's not his question water
yeah water you for giving your baby
water what are you talking about so and
during the medieval period but where did
you get the similac that I'm not
breastfeeding phenomenon has been going
on for the last 10 years but before that
what Chris this is mind numbing this
can't be real this has to be like a
parody she's talking about it like a
trend like it's like a hipster feed your
baby for the past ten years it's kind of
like you know it's you guys are making a
joke about it but she literally said
meetings been around for 10 years this
can't be real
like this is a plant of Fox News plant
oh maybe they paid this Craigslist girl
to make social spores look really dumb
because how can anyone actually be this
dumb believe what this like this would
be one that is stink topic I've never
heard anybody ever say that this is
right so they had they'd had to come up
with that in the Fox News meeting room
having it what's the craziest thing that
we could think of breastfeeding isn't
natural I mean that's a great headline
it's just so obscene conspiracy theory
alert our mothers who weren't all
exactly into breastfeeding you had the
feminism the revolution the 70s women
did not breastfeed like they do nowadays
so what she has not always been the
answer man I'm Kathy thanks for joining
us thanks for having she's a real person
I just think that didn't make sense oh I
don't know 10 years been around for 10
years yeah you know it's been pretty hot
this past decade people are people
started breastfeeding in 2010 did Brad
know I love how she he's like how did
they do it medieval she's like I don't
know but in the last 10 years it's been
real what you know that a knight or some
sort of king or nobleman was not but I'm
gonna feed the baby of milk anyways God
maybe milk milk like hell no no I don't
think you can give comic to babies it's
not good isn't it not good for you
either I don't think I mean well yeah
think about milks for babies
it's for like it's like super fatty and
it's like a lot of high calorie high
density food when your body is rapidly
growing so I I don't think adults are
supposed to drink milk like biologically
kids yeah like you look at for example
an egg an egg has a yolk in it that's
for like a rapidly growing creature
there's a super dense high calorie high
cholesterol food
eggs are like an egg has like 200
percent of your daily value of
cholesterol
I don't it's probably possible the eggs
are not healthy to eat but when you're
growing up as a baby it's essential I
don't know [ __ ] it who cares a lot is
mm-hm
I lack eggs that [ __ ] was mind-bending
huh yeah that was great what about this
dude dude when's competition doesn't
care doesn't care do you make these
notes there was some giveaway in England
and they gave away twenty thousand
pounds that's like thirty or forty
thousand dollars and a brand-new car and
they expect that when they give away
such a huge you know prize that you'd be
super stoked yeah I would be very happy
in fact it's kind of important for the
video like you want to see their
gratitude right make you excited
I wasn't I wasn't the case in this video
this video actually incidentally the guy
doesn't seem to give one single [ __ ] I
have to pee again
damn I know but these videos take like
an hour to get through we talk so much
and posit so much it's almost been three
hours we'll probably are you [ __ ]
kidding me we've been on for three hours
or am I wrong I think so yeah oh my god
these these top of the money's are
pretty intense it's 5:45 we started at
3:00 holy Christ
time really flies me having a good time
is Shay hey I'm a really pretty good
time maybe guys if you leave okay you
don't want to know what happens if you
leave because I will I will kill
everyone in this room you will never see
me you will never get another h3 video
we never get a podcast if you leave I'm
gonna jump I'm gonna take all of them
with me
I'll be back in one minute appreciate
you
I'm getting kind of drunk cool all right
we're back hope he didn't leave cuz I
don't want to in my life I have too much
to live for
and these are great people I don't want
to kill them either Wow we went for I
can't lose been three hours
yeah smokey six million in five months
never been before and PewDiePie is next
do you know he had a live performance we
watched it
Wow weird it was treacherous we're here
somewhere in LA
it was a free show up just one song yeah
just one song I want to show it to you I
want your opinion I would like so we
want subject to their making what we
watch it by the way you saw what did you
see our video about it yeah it's great
what did you think about the whole what
do you think about the whole phenomenon
listen of them of the Jake Paul Robeson
dear friends to stay out of it I mean
that shitty song location man Y 24 and
bio and I'll see you and Ellen Ellen
March like a God Church so we'll end
because it's late so I don't think
people care I think we'll watch it after
we finish
how many people were there it was full
we have two more videos I want to I want
to finish it's fine alright people are
down right they're here at school
are you let me bring it back welcome
back guys we are back with post Malone
and your ela kleiner here the superstar
we have two videos left on them three
videos actually because we want to get
Austin's per reaction to the live
performance of Jake Paul but we'll do
that last all right as we were saying
the guy who's not uh none excited about
the gift here ya like that intros like
here we go yeah yeah my [ __ ] Ranger
that's a great kid a sick great car
that's a great car
yeah it's like fully loaded that's a
beautiful car and it's a surprise this
week's winner he lives just around the
corner
his name is Dominic Holmes and we're
gonna go give him the surprise of a
lifetime surprise of a life that
remember that remember that word that
phrase
I love when they do fast for and don't
take the sound out is it just like rich
or something no he works for our
organization they do giveaways every
month no I mean the guy guy getting I
don't think so that's a really nice
front like optic scanners why would he
answer it then maybe they got doors
doors out of place yeah look it's an old
church is probably really love security
I wonder what was cooking meth or
something in that house cuz it's that
doors really out of place
maybe that's why wasn't excited he's
like get out of here he's like already
of suppose that's an interesting thought
but I just wonder why he would enter it
can't you see my [ __ ] door I don't
care about a car well I assume he
entered so
morning hello it's Dominic in he's not
is it work okay so he just spoken to his
wife and he's not at home and he's gone
into the office so now we're gonna have
to try and track him down at his office
dominate we're coming for you smile face
- joy the car changing people's lives
the joy of giving - he works
I believe I hope these carries just here
so let's hope he's here he hasn't cell
phone because that'd be really good
[ __ ] Range Rover for free there's a
twist - it's even better Railly of
England yeah he's been playing you've
been playing for quite a few years now
he said so the guys clearly involved in
this he's been trying to win for at
least bit more a lot of people that we
surprised there was like you know I
thought one day he's like yeah I know I
rigged this [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah
Christian might turn up on my door I'm
doing really hard already thought you
might be there anyway no don't if I'm
pleased to say you are this week's win
it and you want a brand new Range Rover
Sport I guess not really he's like yeah
maybe didn't want a Range Rover yeah
it's crazy
heard this car sucks I read reviews I'm
pissed
he doesn't look rich although he was
like the Bill Gates thing we're like
your dress
right but I mean what was that garage
like a car rental place where they met
him at work yeah it doesn't seem like a
rich guy you take it in your stride
quite well I've driven a few of these
round London before and they are just as
you London is that like a neighbourhood
in England what is that no they're just
lovely to be in the interiors create the
way they drive is good oh if I'm that
guy I'm like you know what [ __ ] you I'm
right you the next guy get the [ __ ] out
we're just kidding give it to just a
random person on the street it reminds
me of the day we got married I was going
to the ATM and there was a homeless guy
he was panhandling and I was like man
it's my wedding I'm gonna do something
nice for a stranger and I gave him like
a hundred bucks and we were really
broken yeah that was a lot of money for
me and he goes he doesn't say thank you
doesn't show any gratitude he goes so
like what do it like give me more he's
like you must have more money right like
is that can you give me another 50 bucks
and I was like damn did you take it back
I tried to get it back I was like give
me that back dude and I'll give you more
because I was gonna walk off I was kind
of pissed off I was gonna give it to a
different person and he's like no no no
it's fine he never said thank you I was
like really a fun really [ __ ] my ride
yeah he killed my buzz man I was getting
married that day and got me in a funk
damn where are you going I think I just
won man bachelor party you should have
brought him with you let's go dog let's
go get some [ __ ] bow which I don't
know if you remember taking the box full
but if you jump out this might get you
pretty excited here we go
back of head okay so it's game like this
is hard not too excited about there's a
trick in the trunk here only if you want
a brand new Range Rover Sport you also
won 10,000 pounds in cash so Matthew
congratulations again to Dominic Holmes
winning this fantastic range of Nassau
yeah one of you just shy maybe spoken on
it no not that I know of
even if he's rich you would pretend to
be excited right you have some decency
to be like oh this is well he's right
this happens every week every month I
think he said you're the winner of this
week actually you're right you first to
seventh they do this every week so I'm
entering I mentioned I'll be excited
that must have been really disappointing
for him I felt that feeling with the 100
bucks imagine giving away like fifty
sixty thousand dollars yeah more anyway
that was interesting we got one more
look at the dislike read I find that
fine what people dislike a video cuz
they're angry about it but not with the
video itself like they're [ __ ] on
these guys who gave it away cuz they're
pissed about the guy in it it's like
they don't right they're right exactly
is a great job but this guy's a [ __ ] you
know I'm downloading it spend too much
time I read it down though this this
clip hit me real hard this [ __ ] really
shocked me so this is Elon Musk and I'm
a huge fan of Elon Musk of Tesla and
everything he does I think he's an
amazing person
I think he's like a modern-day like Iron
Man he's Tony Hawk Tony Hawk skateboards
like a monster guy's name man Tony Stark
Tony Stark he's like a real-life Tony
started I have so much respect and love
for the man what his vision is for
Humanity but this broke my heart this is
really this just goes to show you that
no matter how rich and success you are
your life's [ __ ] up at 38 Elon is
running SpaceX and Tesla
he's got five boys he's going through a
very public divorce and he's got a new
fiancee so this is a super model that he
just meant like I guess a month ago he's
going through divorce and yeah and
they're they're engaged now so those
aren't her kids
those are his Moebius wife's he's going
through a divorce right now hang on your
worst enemy Elin proposed really quickly
the idea of being swept off your feet is
appealing and I'd probably have said yes
to anyone that seemed half sensible if
they proposed are 10 days just because
it's kind of an interesting thing to do
there that's the first sign of problem I
would say yes to anyone who proposed to
me after a day because it's exciting and
he's sitting there listening to this
[ __ ] right but this [ __ ] gets real like
you can see this hits him hard here
you know straight up to the house with
the children them it became a very real
thing immediately
my parents are traumatized by this whole
experience well there's been so many
times right I'm getting on a plane to
England and I never wait go back
can you believe go back I can this video
is really low okay Elon Musk would have
like the most futuristic house in the
world it's pretty ordinary like I
figured you'd have like [ __ ] iPhones
in your in the floor you could figure
that Eamon must wouldn't be marrying
some like vapid [ __ ] who's like she
says I I fantasized about leaving to
England wait again yeah just play a
little an interesting thing today the
house with the children it became a very
real thing immediately
my parents are traumatized by this whole
experience no there's been so many times
I've said I'm getting about England I'm
never seeing you again
really that's super sad and it's in this
show like the way that she was walking
out where the [ __ ] are you going yeah I
had I think they filmed that after the
scene because you know why'd they leave
this in yeah that's why I'm heavy
well that's a great moment if you're a
filmmaker why did he want even open
himself up to make himself disavowal no
no but luck watches are serious he's
genuinely sad no no not really
wait uh are they still together cause
people are asking I wonder
that's a really great question let's
find out let me just get my [ __ ]
future car move on take a ride fiance I
don't know if they got married yet so I
guess so maybe [ __ ] I mean here that's
her right I think or maybe that's his
previous wife that looks just like her
you just got a thing for girls that look
like that someone is saying they're not
married - I'm not surprised by that yeah
they're divorced here 2013 and 2016 Wow
crazy oh but they were married before
that - I guess they were together for a
minute no this is a different girl oh
wait oh my god you're right they got
divorced together for three years
divorced again [ __ ] that [ __ ] is what
I'm saying that's brutal
Elon Musk endured torture and married
virgin he met wait what are you right
there the first link it says virgin this
one married virgin billionaire Elon Musk
endured psychological torture from his
father told his first wife she was fired
and then married the 22 year old virgin
even at a London club telling her he
wanted to show her his rocket what this
has gotta be some I didn't know anything
about him though he could be a really
shitty husband to be fair true he could
be really [ __ ] I shouldn't I shouldn't
call her [ __ ] me I love her but that
was very rude thing to do on television
he's living in the future he has no time
for the president dude he was very sad
and all the iPhones in the floor in the
world could have made so yeah it's a
great video that's everything that's not
a great video but it's fascinating
fascinating that's pretty bad man your
Outlook account
are set out of date this is turning into
a disaster I feel but I have this bad
habit of calling women like [ __ ]
sometimes when I'm referring to them I
don't like doing that mm-hmm I always do
it but I was like angry at her yeah she
was being [ __ ] I think she was being
[ __ ] yeah maybe she's not a [ __ ]
she was she's acting [ __ ] thank you I
agree with that I don't think so we got
Jake Paul you so let's let's wrap it up
we're gonna I want Austen's reaction to
Jake Paul every day bro lot before we
leave we're gonna do a little post show
we'll hang out with you guys take some
questions whatever you know by the way
next episode I think we booked so Flo
mm-hmm so Flo Antonio's coming on our
show next I'm excited you want to be
here I'm gonna be here are you serious
yes ma'am
yeah oh my god easy next Friday
what's that date let's see 16 16 knock
it off so Flo dad what if he gonna
handle being smoked out what is the
hotbox cigarettes tell he's handled
yes survival spreads cancer of the world
he could handle a couple cigarettes Ari
I mean I didn't he yeah that's what
we're doing here right I have two beers
and I'm losing my mind he's looking fly
got half of a denim jacket on a camel II
do all the commentary here Oh me yeah
wait what about your song are you guys
gonna do your song in front of him
we we already confirmed with him that
he's down to do the camp yeah I'm
excited we got to do it need to get back
in uh yeah yeah no you're busy whenever
you got time let's see what we'll see
what these guys
featuring 210 is that the English guy
that's his whole girl he's a little diva
first song ever and he's being a diva
he's got a m16 on his jacket that's not
it
he's hard that's not it that's not it
[Music]
that's at a sink by the way Oh Ohio
though white boy white boy
[Music]
Oh living you know his brother they had
some guy recorded two heads of beef they
had some fake beef on Twitter I'm just
kidding I I don't know I have become the
master he got it's like it's like Taylor
Swift and Kim Kardashian how she
recorded her on the phone it's that epic
but yeah who do you think it's with I
don't know Jesus I know about you Jesus
step off me me tell the truth
my first thought on that line was that's
illegal in California what you can't
record somebody without their consent
right I was like you better not really
not even a misdemeanor misdemeanor if
anybody knows who he's talking about in
the yeah I'll check the chat it's
probably his ex-girlfriend or something
I don't know I mean I just hope it's
YouTube beef I hope it's some spicy beef
with the landside rice on the side a
little spicy chicken some canes some
games chicken you love games
I [ __ ] love cane I had some at the
house all right somebody was saying his
ex yeah that's right dog cuz she was in
like Logan's dis truck the whole thing
is just a bunch of crab canes in LA it
is an hour away and I had a sprinter
pull up to my house early and they
brought it you had something to live it
for my own way well I'm going to San
Diego for like a club show tonight so he
just came early and brought it but I was
asleep you didn't get it no you don't
you still there though you don't you eat
it cold you'll get down yeah
it's kids basic [ __ ] games what if
you guys know what Keynes is like this
insane fried chicken when like bread
they just give you like this toasted
fried bread it's the most delicious and
this is nasty like mayonnaise dipping
sauce it's not NAT like yeah either
remembers that sauce ela got the sauce
like sauce - Mike like can you imagine
writing a lyrical on your songs that
said post Malone is number one I want
like I don't understand I don't
understand
this is flabbergasted by how this can
exist yeah how people can like this is
the type of [ __ ] that I was making when
I was 14 right yeah like those are like
14-year old me lyrics like I am Number
One catch me chew I'm like it's gum well
you know I have a saying I say whenever
something inexplicable happens
especially on YouTube that you don't
understand the answer is invariably
always the same kids cuz you're asking
like who's watching this kids kids but
you saw the audience they're all I think
the average audience age is 12 yeah I'm
[ __ ] dead I will show you the
audience here they do a close up later
I'll pause it and show you well it goes
like here look I dare you to find
someone in the bottom right he's like
six years old he does not impress that
kids like are you serious Doug can you
find anyone over the age of 13 no no if
they had made it like 18 and up it would
be like rager yeah like yeah exactly
you guys yeah just go for the meme of it
I would go for the mean by this thing I
would go I can't hang without crowd lady
they're like Jake polish - they would
like probably kill me like hey we just
take me down they would trip you [ __ ] up
they eat my corpse we were saying we
already know
this guy to me for some reason is the
saddest yeah I don't know why he's
trying so hard but like he has this
moment where he's they don't have enough
mics for everyone so he passes it off to
Jake and then like sadly slunk sin to
the background that's coming up I think
he is the most talented rapper really of
the group but the bar is quite low yeah
yeah but he is trying way too hard maybe
that's the problem right I think that's
what it is you just see him
and his hair right and his his half C
shirt [ __ ] him and his shirt [ __ ]
shirt wear shirts seriously I never worn
a shirt on natural it is a racist for
you to they wearing 10 years ago this
shirt crazy shirts are really into the
past 10 years
[Music]
look at that he doesn't even finish his
lied he doesn't even get to finish his
verse he's like here you go look he
looks so he looks sarcastic handing the
mic off almost he looks sad like he
realized it's over it's just like there
you go
he doesn't finish his line that's the
saddest part is what do you mean they
don't have a [ __ ] mic for the for the
[ __ ] Teamster let's do it in slow-mo
so you can watch the dude just had a
million subs last month where's my mic
where's my mic I have a gold play button
that's part of his lyrics isn't it but
it's like like two months or six months
four thousand four hundred thousand
sorry
yeah that's not I mean that's that's
good I don't know if it's worth bragging
about in a rap right it's not what you
are Mike can you judge your swag by the
level of subs that you have you can't
certainly they are doing it here but he
came at PewDiePie was like dude Jake
Paul is getting a million subscribe
that's what set me off but Jake Paul is
getting a million subscribers a month
which is insane that's a super high rate
and what does he do I know what his
brother does they do the same [ __ ] same
[ __ ] yeah but here's what he's saying
pewdiepie I'm gonna pass you next great
a million subs a month would still take
him like five years
look he's at 65 million like dude that
will take you you'll be an adult you
realize how cringe you are by the time
you pass Beauty but you'll want to close
your channel there's no possible way
yeah it's not happening well here's this
slow-mo
look how sad he is right like you didn't
get to finish his line it's like damn I
gotta give it up to this [ __ ]
egotistical maniac you can't I don't
know if you can pass up a mic like that
in a cool way
I don't think so I think you just need
to do it before like and like in the
beginning it wasn't cool it's not cool
right like there's no way to pull that
off so I guess I can't blame him you
think he's disappointed with that age
turnout hopefully they weren't surprised
by that it's like damn I thought I would
have some cool swag guys he's a gap I
can't even [ __ ] these kids he could
be good like technically technically he
could technically you can [ __ ] anything
honestly if you want to get into it
[ __ ] breastfeeding you could [ __ ] the
breastfeeding you could figure that out
someone's figured these kids are kind of
worse him the oldest person a similar
way it really off
[Music]
yeah you're right it could be in Sunset
Park easily we should start our own
would that be great
we should move it out no but really I
need a place to live so like can you do
it I got 40 bucks for you I got a room
for you dog team actually have a kid in
Austin's living with us whole weird
reality show sounds great I'd watch why
is this guy in spanish back to this so
they're actually I thought there's from
Spain they're Spanish they speak English
though rapid Spanish just to bring that
like it's nice yeah like hey you can
[ __ ] up you could [ __ ] a a white boy
from Ohio you'd also get a little spicy
and weird strange ass some strange
little exotic little twink boy that's
been yeah cilona oh hey we I am going to
Rome for my birthday and I would love
for you guys to comment you serious my
birthday's on the 25th and we've been
planning a holiday for it we were
thinking about last month yeah okay mine
is July 4th wolf your all-american what
wait when are you going away you're
going to Rome I think we're gonna be in
Europe and then we'll go to Rome on the
3rd and stay there for like 4 days and
just go fast but gang midnight boys 12
o'clock bikes up guns down you already
know yo I've always actually want like
Hawaii and Rome or the top of Rome is
the most I've been there one time and I
wanted to go since I was a little kid
because I was I was always into like
that [ __ ] like like the history of it
yeah like the Roman Empire and the cows
Wow I think we'll come I think well
actually we were literally planning a
vacation we share birthday everybody's
gonna be there it's gonna be sick that's
time we gotta Airbnb right across from
the college the pictures are crazy we
need to do it again Vespa gang so fun
I'm coming is there a gang does that
require you to wear something yellow you
yellow if you want to
so we need to our yellow I'll get yellow
Vespers Vespa gang twelve O'Clock bikes
up guards down Vespa gay let's go I I
genuinely think we're gonna come nope
y'all so roam on the 3rd of July 3rd
yeah see you there I'll get you more
detail everything that's gonna be
[ __ ] if they have any haunted
locations they're very like anal about
like all the history like I'm sure
there's hella haunted places oh come on
how many people died there seriously
somebody goes I lose count of them all
exactly like man I ain't got time for
this ghost all these ghosts stalking me
I found a rock and I found a rock and my
friend had a nightmare there so like I
found this rock like from the street and
I took it yeah and assumed the night
that I got it my friend had like a
nightmare that someone was like standing
over his bed it wasn't even a nightmare
it was like he thought someone was in
the room with him how come you guys
correlated that to the rock well I don't
know because it's just strange that we
were in this house for like four days
and nothing happened and then I get this
like five hundred year old rock haunted
stone yeah well I mean it could be a
thing ugly and so I so I put it back
where'd you find the stone in the street
what kind of stone was it cobblestone
from the rug from the city of Europe in
the city of your country of Rome Rome is
my country I'm genuinely excited to go
there yeah that's gonna be all gonna be
good guys I've always wanted time I went
we went to the Loki spots like where the
capuchin monks made art out of bones and
show Wow they threw all these monks
because everybody was dying at that time
from the Black Plague yeah something
like that I think it was about
me on it okay everybody was dying and
they threw all these monks into a like a
pile like cuz you know everybody was
just dying it like an alarming rate yeah
and then like the three like holiest
monks are like a bunch of holy monks
just wouldn't like what's the word
whenever you die I don't know like
decompose okay they wouldn't decompose
and I'll go to this place and they still
have hair like they start from like
2,000 years ago I won't and you can
still see these bodies hopefully they
made art out of it hopefully they still
don't hide the plague on them wanna go
there super sick and I'll take you to
like a church so there's an 18th century
Church and whenever they went there like
the the head priest like kept hearing
water and he was like where's this
running water coming from and so they
kept digging down and they found
underneath that they found a 14th
century church Wow and underneath the
14th century church they found a coin
press 12 12th century coin press and
they kept going into like a fourth
century like pagan ritual site where
they sacrifice bulls and then they
finally found like running water like
boiling water underneath like layers of
buildings that stills running today
it's crazy where you learn the history
in that do they tell I had a guide now
we could go and like yeah that's one of
the coolest historical places in the
world I was blown away oh my god I can't
wait I'm genuinely excited and there was
so much art there sick I still need to
go to the like the Vatican in the
Sistine Chapel they got everything there
so got the food they got history they
got art the most beautiful
yeah we're getting I think she's on that
sector
she's maybe trying to sing
[Music]
is that your boys Cologne I think it's
the first show ever
it's kind of strange they rolled up for
one show then a one song just one song
and then they balanced it think that's
it yeah just one song cuz that's all
they got
I hope they make an album that'll be
something I'm one hand like I have to
knowledge like am I going too hard on
these kids they just like having fun
young man how old is Jake Paul I think
he's like 20 21 22 22 maybe I don't know
I think he's being disrespectful just
the way like the way that he came at
several people interact beauty yeah what
do you think is a serious artist like
this is a serious to it he's he does it
for a career he is good at it people
like it and he's like yo yeah I'll let
you have your [ __ ] spot back whenever
the ballers are [ __ ] done till then
this is my spot yes like five hours well
we made our video wasn't on there at all
buddy you're right I mean yeah you're
right I mean but also it's just sour
like amazingly bad the song it's like
whenever Beckham black man that's true
and they think it's probably hot as [ __ ]
oh yeah yeah it's crazy okay good so I'm
justified I'm justified I hope maybe
we'll have beads I'm sure that I I'm
sure they don't like me cuz I had that
encounter with Logan oh yeah what
happened then I told you about that
right whatever I saw him at in one of
notches parties one of his crazy parties
the guy who made minecraft he was like
the most expensive house in LA it's
crazy and I ran into Logan there after I
made my video with
i dubs and i didn't tell you this and he
goes to me basically it was mad yeah he
was upset he's really upset
he's next to this bright red Mustang
it's like a it's like a art piece in his
house and I walk up to him like oh my
god it's logan paul and without thinking
i wasn't trying to be rude or me and i
was just trying to be funny i didn't
think about it and i go up to him like
hey what color is that car it's like
we're bright red like how could i not
say that and then he turns to me and i'm
trying to shake his hand be like hey
dawg it's cool right and he goes he
won't shake my hand and he's like he's
like doing this yeah and then he goes I
fantasized about what I'd say if I ran
into you then would it be late and he
was he's like I think I was gonna say
something about you having how you have
pubes on your face and I was like that
had been dug that would been really cool
why did he say that first as a precursor
that he was gonna be cool but I think it
really hit him hard but it's like Doug
you're killing it you're on top of the
game like I rarely have the opportunity
to punch up anymore like back in the day
when we were first coming up everyone
was way bigger than us so we could talk
shown anybody because we were just the
small pea right but now these days it's
hard because I don't want to make fun of
some little ass yeah it's no fun and
it's just mean I never get the
opportunity to punch up and these guys
are killing it man they're absolutely
murdering it so it's like he's actually
way more successful than we are so for
me I get that opportunity to like punch
up make fun of someone more successful
than you right so it's not like a
pathetic mean thing to do and it's like
that I don't know yeah you're in the
spot like people are gonna goof on you
no I don't know why you gotta take it so
personally so I was surprised by that it
was very awkward and it was very awkward
luckily with one of his projects tur
yeah one of the day oh he did well
appreciate him i I honestly logan's from
so wait you're siding with this [ __ ]
please I do want to say for the record
like obviously it's not real genuine
hate it small part of the game right
like we're just goofing around we're
making fun of people you know it's why
we don't know what I mean you could tell
I think you can tell about a lot about
that I'm the initial meeting yeah that's
true I get [ __ ] talking about me all the
time who talk [ __ ] about me I still met
them with my face and I say what's up
with that yeah but I'm a grown person
yeah I think he's been famous but he was
really famous on vine even before he
blew up on YouTube so I can't imagine
that it's the first time it's someone's
Ross probably although people have been
blasting Jake on like a whole new level
I feel like everyone this is bad but you
know everyday bro is in the top 20 most
disliked videos on all of YouTube now
can we see that let's see is it on you
is that a chart on you yeah yeah yeah
you can actually view it yep pull it up
let me see how many dislikes it actually
has so it's still in the posit but it
has 800,000 dislikes 30 million views I
mean likes you know you're killing it
Jake as far as I can tell has been
taking it fine
I mean Logan seem to be taking a fine
too because in his videos yeah yeah I
thought it was cool cuz he used this
edit where he's like haha my strawberry
he used that one of his videos
afterwards so I thought he was mean he
was rolling with the punches but I guess
he was took it kind of personally we
need to see the comments on this let's
get to number one on iTunes fam you
should delete that you should erased
that comment now go now um
Engel is in the city sorry to break it
to you Jake Paul saw saw a [ __ ] then he
walked away from the mirror the other
plays his song in his concentration
camps YouTube commas are the worst place
on this planet am I the only one waiting
for one mil dislikes I can't believe
people actually like the [ __ ] there's
not even one nice one
England is my city I'm crying this is
way this is way cancer doesn't have a
cure maybe why
this is why people uploaded that still
they don't care guys remember when Jake
ball had Talent yeah me neither
be honest I came to dislike and leave to
even out the score which one I want to
commit suicide it's so blatant it's so
just straightforward easy to be honest
like let's pretend this is infinite
warfare trailer guys I wish I could
dislike this so much you can anyway it's
all hey but you know what there kill his
response to hate you want to watch that
new video but the thing here's the
problem with their [ __ ] videos it's
24 minutes long who has time for that
you probably did let's just skip to the
part where dress that welcome this
morning to allegations that were being
made by ELISA towards me and like oh
it's about the neckline of this story
not interested at all seriously ah so
then they're like okay normal blog we
have to watch this for 20 minutes to get
to the [ __ ] point this is maybe kind
of a nerdy just skip to 14 minutes by
the way for the record I mean the video
I thought it was hilarious I was like yo
what's good like my friends thought it
was funny I put it online the video get
off [ __ ] it he's talking about this girl
ex-girlfriend oh I'm gonna watch this
later
yeah alright well I guess that concludes
this episode of the top of the month top
of the morning to you laddies yeah hope
you guys enjoy it let us know cuz we'll
do one of these every month we'll put
together our favorite videos mmm it was
a lot of fun I think it was it was great
yeah I mean you know I got a little
drunk I said some things that's part of
doing a live [ __ ] it we'll go alive okay
we'll do it I don't say something dumb
at least two or three or four ten things
or anything too damn good so listen
let's turn it over to the live stream
and see what's good over here we got
again we got our beers back up yeah
they're back it's popping like my collar
it's popping what's the most
like video Oh baby right baby bye Justin
Bieber really I think so
let me fund a list most disliked videos
on YouTube there's nothing that's a
great [ __ ] song
Oh Wikipedia is a [ __ ] article though
yeah Justin Bieber well he probably also
has like one of the most likes to ever
yeah yeah I mean so baby baby I don't
know why who would go and dislike that
like it's a it's a it's a hit song if
it's not your thing because it's still
very professional I wouldn't waste my
time go just like baby baby great song I
think that's the most viewed video too
but what do you expect so it kind of
comes what was six billion Wow look how
young he is that's really surprising
seven years ago
whoa that's crazy I think people were
still just found out about Justin here
but I mean that was like the phase where
it was cool to hate on him yeah I don't
think maybe he gets that much I got no I
[ __ ] with everything like this is a
great song I mean he is he's a talented
guy he's super talented super successful
it's just a magnet for hate so you know
take a note from the Biebs Paul boys
exactly exactly I mean that guy gets
more hate than anyone but he's crushing
it it's crazy I saw a video with Justin
Bieber getting harassed by TMZ down in
uh Beverly Hills when he was shopping
and you really humanized him for me he's
super play a good guy he was super play
super nice is that please leave me alone
I'm just hanging with my dogs and they
got the the tabloid guys were so [ __ ]
rude what if I can find that it was I
was like damn Justin Bieber seems like a
decent [ __ ] guy he's a really dope
dude I've known him for like a year and
a half he's a really sweet guy
like ever since I met him like he was
just always super down-to-earth and
super cool that's awesome he's a really
good friend okay I think this is it yeah
Justin you got some serious hot sake for
hockey skills would you ever try to go
pro shut up question did he say you has
some serious hot sake everything about
haha go away man there's got to be a
better day job than this what was the
deal with that guy the other day at the
game you guys piece it out
you can tell they've been harassing him
all day to Canadian woods you sing it
swamps inauguration the me like what
normal human action interaction is like
come on guys please leave me alone and
then it's like I didn't hear you at all
right great
it's got to be maddening I love it
it's [ __ ] brilliant everything about
going pro hockey yes the series hot
soccer hockey skills you would think
about gold bro I can't believe you said
does a film question your diva he's
looking for somebody to sing that's why
it's gotta be so hard being the most
famous person in the world he is really
like top five most famous people in the
world I feel like that's why I have so
much respect for him like keeping [ __ ]
composure
dude it's that's so true I mean like
it's got to get matting and then when
these guys mob you then it becomes a
scene mm-hmm all the sudden you're
walking around your mind your own
business and he's probably low-key you
get mobbed by these parasites I can't
tell you like I went to I was looking at
my place in Nevada right and that's a
small ass little town and one kid seen
me and then he calls all of his friends
we literally I was shopping at the store
and literally 40 of his friends show up
Wow when I had to show love to all of
them and I love showing love to my fans
but I'm I'm one trillionth as famous as
Justin and I could only imagine like the
[ __ ] that he goes yeah you can't go you
can't you can't do anything right
anywhere yes yes a different level he's
been on [ __ ] tour for like three
years has he really crazy that's mad
yeah surprising the indoors for that I
must be exhausting he's a superhero I
love that
listen to me people are laughing yeah
how many people are there influenced the
whole not talking thing I know that was
his move W years ago I'm just you know
I'm just hanging out with my boy you
gonna walk down the damn street right
but it seems like it suddenly started
he's best God because in deep I
appreciate that you get him [ __ ] him up
he deserves it TMZ has like been in my
face before mm-hmm but they never like
like hockey harassed me that's what's
happening kind of here when you ask
someone to leave you alone and they
don't right right right in public area
think so dumb questions are you asking
well thank you for pointing that out
alright thanks Justin
oh the videos longer but then like he
goes to shopping into the store and
they're waiting outside for him filming
the whole thing my god that's pretty
crazy anyway most disliked videos do a
game suck ass
PewDiePie can I get 1 million dislikes
Friday gangam style
wrecking ball
people are haters man how is it [ __ ] bop
what is that I see a really great
question is it a song
let me just google it cuz sure what the
[ __ ] is on oh wow it's got to be pretty
bad well I've never seen wow look at
that oh wait I feel like we're in for
some gold I think so too I have to pee
goddammit even guys we're taking a break
[ __ ] you guys don't leave let's do it
all night I mean we're until we're done
we'll probably be here for another hour
okay guys I'm gonna go Pete we're just
getting started
I'll be right back in two minutes eh wha
so anyway where were we we were looking
at most disliked videos of all time on
YouTube and this one's like number five
and we never heard of it so I'm
fascinated let's give it a watch
production value offer it looks I have a
feeling it's Patrice I don't know why I
know that's not a job
maybe I'm wrong
[Music]
have to do
[Music]
say I feel so fast
[Music]
but psycho why die
pretty wild right
so I mean I don't know what
what is this video mine is something
crazy gonna happen victory is gonna pop
out in a panda suit I just think people
are hating on her I don't know
oh here we go
but beat at Bobby I know the lyrics but
I need it out of my butt let's go Bobby
got one
smoking on purple clay I mean okay I
mean yeah it's not my taste but go down
read the comments how do i people hating
so much 40 million views is quite a lot
papa bless wait oh okay I was like what
the [ __ ]
paella wait let me go sir bye oh there
German I think okay it wasn't an English
phenomenon I think it was a German thing
she must be some German star oh wow it's
all German okay this isn't from our
world well the Germans really hate this
girl oh you read German
I'm just saying all the comments are
German so I assume all the dislikes like
I think the population of Germany is
like 50 million so that means like one
dislike for everybody some rich dudes
trophy wife and he paid for the video
yeah it's all German or maybe Dutch I
don't know they look very similar
interesting okay well sorry lady what
about the other videos sorry lady you
got a lead on someone who's saying that
next Friday you're at Massachusetts
that's [ __ ] hilarious it's probably
true that's fine we're gangam anaconda
they people just hate these are all just
videos with a ton of views so they get
more dislikes what about that Russian
song where oh wow what the [ __ ] his name
in English and clearly that's a stupid
statement massa and the bear how do I
find this see
try to find the [ __ ] Sika sooo complete
wait what what video are we talking
about here
now this isn't at 37,000 what is this I
came and find it let me do a search for
this Russian business this is number 12
I find it fascinating how a whole
country can just hate on one video this
is it 2.2 billion so yeah but it's up
there up there holy [ __ ] it's
fascinating
did you some random kids kidding me
[Laughter]
[Music]
how the [ __ ] does this get 2.2 billion
2.2 billion that's a lot how many people
live in Russia a shitload not 2.2
billion yeah oh it's like a silent film
I know what people hating is just a
normal kitchen but I don't know that I
don't understand it is this is
fascinating this is weird this is just
weird
Wow let me look at the comments yeah
it's all Russian are you gonna hit a
billion Congrats you're in the minority
there people hate this [ __ ] wow this is
really interesting Wow Nicki's on there
twice Johnny Johnny yes papa you know
that video 1.1 billion dislikes I don't
know how these we just get a billion
views oh it's an hour long [ __ ] me whoa
I got time for this knees and toes
get on with the Papa [ __ ]
[Music]
other [ __ ] does this get a billion views
be an hour long till how long do you
have to watch a video for it down I'm
not watching this it's an hour long
[Music]
this is like a lance vlog alright let's
take some some questions from the
audience here you guys got any questions
for us do a podcast with the rock yeah
sure
simple do it do a podcast with President
Obama okay we'll work on that
hi guys with Jesus Christ kids are
[ __ ] I guess by the nature that's
true post do you love me yeah I do
confirm Jess is there any mods here this
we have like no mods there's got to be
someone there right well we can't expect
them to like hang out here forever
imagine if we just modded everyone I
wonder what kind of man what do you what
do you mod so mods they like moderate
the chat they could put them like slow
mode so you can only comment every 30
seconds they could put in subscribe mode
so only subscribers they can ban people
who are spamming so usually like a
twitch stream like this will have like
many active mods right but we don't know
what we're doing so we don't know anyone
of controlling this total so there's no
mods oh I think it's in okay someone did
I don't know someone just put in sub
only mode let me end it so then we can
do like that also we have let me do it
let me wrap it up and then we can do the
post show guys thanks for watching I
think I already do it again guys thanks
for watching I know it got a little
messy here at the end but we have a lot
of fun doing this the top of the month
top of the morning to you if you guys
enjoyed it will be doing every month
we'll be doing it every month anyway it
cuz it's tough and it's fun but I hope
you guys enjoy it if you want to support
us link your Amazon account with twitch
and you can support us for free by
subscribing every month it's a beautiful
wonderful thing or by some of our March
at represent com4 / h3 street and you
can get this amazing shirt thanks for
joining us we love you we appreciate you
and we will be seeing you next time bye
guys okay that's where we cut mmm-hmm
now we're slamming bye
we do have mods peepee nerd yeah yes
someone moderated and snipers snipers
always monks was he my god he's one of
our old YouTube friends he's like and I
don't know if he invented but he's like
the grandfather of remember MLG mmm-hmm
montages yeah snipers he was like the
big boy in that damn oh [ __ ]
cataclysmic disaster yeah I'm real big
knife said he's been here the whole time
god bless you Snipes god bless you
Snipes and I would love you just a 360
double-wide noscope crossed Matt meet ya
right into my heart he did that actually
he makes some here's a fashion line
called pearly whites I gave you yeah
super super dope birdly right yeah he's
a cool guy real interesting guy
you went for making montage parodies to
fashion yeah interesting guy aware of
many hats
he's a hat boy well I'm kind of
exhausted [ __ ] there's been a long one
hmm we got a letter our life switcher
off feel bad for him mostly have you
snipers snipe ours
it's my fires yeah I want to get Tai
Lopez on I see people saying that I
think we'll get tie on to all right I
think I'm gonna end it guys it's been a
joy it's been a lot of fun thanks for
coming out and joining us this was a
real fun experiment it was fun it was a
lot of fun we had a couple moments we
had old situations that's that's so
that's so yes but no longest dream ever
I'm exhausted shits how long will I like
for five hours five hours Christ I'll
night I hope you guys have a wonderful
weekend and be good stay tuned
thanks for supporting us you guys are
the
yeah and ethan ela are dropping for new
videos tomorrow doesn't work like that
alright guys it takes us a lot man our
new video it was I was crying I didn't
leave the house for like three days
you're busy you guys are the best thanks
for joining us there's been a lot of fun
we'll see you guys next Friday love it
love being here caught it